So, sollte an sein.
Hallo, Leute.
Hallo, alle Channel-Camper,
die es gibt.
Ich habe nämlich heute schon wieder Comments im Chat gesehen.
Moment, läuft es jetzt?
Ja, perfekt.
Ich muss jetzt mal gucken, ob man das
Overlay sieht.
Discord-Overlay.
Hallo, ng0.0.
Äh, sie...
ng0.0, ist klar.
ng0.
Äh...
Also, das Discord-Overlay
sieht man nicht. Das ist aber ganz schön
blöd.
Was ist denn, wenn ich das hier jetzt einblende?
Sehe ich es dann?
Überschreibt sich das nicht?
Mit links?
Ah, ich gucke gerade mal.
Nee, eigentlich nicht.
Okay, man kann das
aber in OBS, habe ich gesehen, kann man irgendwo
ein Häkchen machen. Capture
In-Game-Overlay und
sowas. Das geht.
Capture Third-Party-Overlay, such as
Steam.
Jetzt sieht man es.
Perfekt.
Jetzt sieht man es. Sehr schön.
Jetzt kann ich nur mal das Game einstellen.
Ja.
Oh, habe ich Titel
und so geändert? Game, Overwatch,
Titel, wo sind die Mercy-Mains, wenn man sie braucht?
Ja, das passt, oder?
Das passt nicht, dass es wieder so wird wie gestern.
Also, heute müsste es von der Lautstärke
auch ziemlich gut passen.
Ich müsste ungefähr gleich laut sein.
Ich habe jetzt sogar
das Discord-Overlay am Start,
dass man sieht, wer was sagt
und dass man nicht verwirrt ist, was da so viele Leute
labern und so. Ich glaube, das ist
heute ganz gut.
Und jetzt erst mal ein, zwei Runden aufwärmen.
Brauchen wir das? Auf dem Bank
aufwärmen? Nee, nee, wir spielen gleich
ranked. Aber halt, aufwärmen.
Dann sitzen die Hooks auch wieder.
Das waren die ersten zwei Runden gestern.
Boah, ey.
Nichts getroffen.
Scheiße.
Easy Wits.
Ich habe auf Deutsch installiert.
Was hast du?
Da kannst du einfach umstellen in Settings.
Naja, ich mach grad.
Dann lädt er noch ein paar Gigabyte runter und dann ist gut.
Oder ein paar MB.
So groß sind ja die Language-Files nicht.
Er könnte etwas lauter sein.
Echt?
Also, laut
dem Ausschlag
im OBS,
wenn der Eax was sagt und wenn ich was sage,
ist das ungefähr gleich laut.
Ich könnte mich einfach einen Ticken leiser machen.
So, easy.
Ich kann dich noch einen Ticken lauter machen.
Das geht auch.
So, jetzt bist du noch ein bisschen lauter.
Wunderbar.
So, jetzt so müsste es aber passen, denke ich.
Du findest mich minimal lauter.
Gut, dann mache ich ihn noch einen Ticken lauter.
Sollte ja gehen.
Ich bin so froh, dass ich einen Mixer, also das Audio-Interface davor habe,
wo ich noch außerhalb von OBS ein bisschen Zeug regeln kann.
Hast du gerade das Wort mit W oder mit W?
Ja.
Ich habe mit M angefangen.
Hä, was meinst du?
Dein Mixer.
Ich habe einen Mixer, ja? Richtig.
Beziehungsweise ein Audio-Interface, ja?
Da sind schon Momente, da müssen wir ja hier
die richtigen Fachbegriffe verwenden.
Ich hatte letztens einen in-Game irgendwie,
hatte so einen ultra bescheuerten Namen.
Wie hieß der denn? Irgendwie...
Irgendwas im Battlefield letztens irgendwie
Wixmutt oder so der Name genannt.
Wixmutt ist down.
Max, nach einer Runde Starcraft...
Starcraft? Nein.
Starcraft 1 habe ich mal gespielt.
Das ist aber schon 15 Jahre oder so her.
Ne, ne...
Gibt es da was Neues? Starcraft-technisch?
Forever, nex.
Ich guck mal, ob das Muten funktioniert.
Ja, Muten funktioniert.
Da labere ich den Eax nicht voll, wenn ich mit dem Chat rede.
Ja, oben links ist das Discord-Interface.
Interface. Ja, genau.
Das ist jetzt neu. Das gab's
vorher auch schon, aber das in der Form ist
jetzt neu. Gab's heute Morgen ein Update
im Discord.
Ist mittlerweile free-to-play StarCraft, ja, stimmt.
So, ähm,
ich invite dich mal, ne?
Mhm. Warte, ich muss mal
den Booker anmachen. Baust du auch einen Playlist?
Ähm, ich, ne, ich mach hier
irgendwas an. Ich mach auch erst,
ich glaub, ich mach erst mal ein bisschen zum
zum Waren werden, erst mal ohne Musik.
So.
Ja, dann lass mal loslegen.
Was haben wir denn gestern plus gemacht?
So 180 circa? Ja, wir haben gestern
relativ viel gewonnen, ne?
Irgendwie, keine Ahnung, sieben, acht
Games gewonnen, drei verloren oder sowas.
So aus dem Bauch raus, würd ich mal so sagen.
Na ja, mal gucken. Okay. Also heute ist Master
bestimmt, ne? Easy Master.
Hab kein Ding.
Pass auf, jetzt kriegen wir
erst mal die übelsten Flaschen
schnellstelle. So, ich cure.
Aber erst mal aufwärmen.
So, Motivationsmusik
anmachen.
Auf geht's.
Würdest du eigentlich, warte mal, ich mute mich, wa?
Äh, würdest du eigentlich auch für dein
YouTube-Video StarCraft als Hintergrund-Gameplay nehmen?
Äh, als Hintergrund-Gameplay
ähm, ist StarCraft so ne Sache?
Ich, wobei, warum eigentlich?
Mad. Wollte grad sagen, man versteht halt
nicht, was passiert, wenn man sich mit dem Game nicht beschäftigt hat.
Ich guck ja immerhin ab und zu mal ein paar Streams.
Das heißt, ich weiß so grob, was abgeht.
Ähm, ich kann's halt überhaupt
nicht einschätzen richtig.
Außerdem sind die meisten Leute
übelst auf Shooter-Gameplay eingeschworen
mittlerweile.
Endlich können wir wieder gute
Mercy-Gameplays genießen, euer...
Ich ahne es schon.
Wo sind die
Mercy-Mains, wenn man sie braucht?
Ja, alle Grandmasters, hast du ja
gestern schon gesagt.
Ja.
Es war der Wahnsinn gestern. Mich hat das voll gewundert.
Wo sind die alle hin?
Ja, schlimm.
Sonst hast du irgendwelche
Mercy-Main-Grills, die immer...
am Start sind und gestern
alle Games, nix.
Komisch. Ganz, ganz merkwürdig.
Äh, ich könnte den Stream auf Twitter posten.
Hört mir grad ein.
Äh, war gepostet.
Wie einfach Twitter immer noch den falschen Titel
für meinen Stream hat. Das haben die wahrscheinlich
irgendwann mal gecached vor fünf Tagen.
Ist nicht mehr geupdatet.
Ähm...
Vielleicht ist Mercy dem zu schwer, wenn er es klauen hat.
Easy.
Oh, easy. Ich mach Speed.
Lucio zum Einspielen.
Ist wunderbar. Da muss man sich ein bisschen moven.
Und ich kann's
aus dem Schlaf spielen.
Ah, guck mal. Wir haben ganz viele
DPS.
Wunderlich, dass wir so viele DPS haben.
Gab's jemals ein Game?
Überleg mal ganz scharf. Gab's irgendwo
ein Game, wo du mal Mangelware an DPS
hattest?
Hab kein Spiel gespielt, was sowas...
Gibt's nicht.
Jetzt gibt's nicht.
DPS ist immer genug.
Sogar in MMOs.
DPS hast du wie Sand am Meer.
Auch scheiß DPS.
Heiler hast du auch noch recht viel,
aber Tanks hast du keine.
Du musst dir mal überlegen.
Es ist so, Spiele wie League of Legends,
da kannst du ja mittlerweile deine Rolle rauswählen.
Da hast du das Problem gar nicht.
Guck mal, der Gegner.
Moment, sag mal, kann das sein, dass ich
Single Support spiele gerade?
Mit Lucio.
Haha, der Roadhog, wie er nix trifft.
Ich lass mal hier laufen bei euch.
Killsteal.
Mach gerne mal Onspot.
Okay, die wollen nicht geheilt werden.
Kommt keiner her.
Harambe!
Wie alt YOLO reingesprungen ist, so.
Oh, wir haben eine Orisa.
Hört mir jetzt erst auf.
Deswegen stehen wir hier wenigstens noch ein bisschen.
Oh, Carino.
Oh, oh, oh, der Roadhog ist direkt neben uns.
Es könnte sein, dass wir backcapped werden.
Oh, ho, ho, ho, ho.
Rekt.
Nein.
Der Sam Fischer schreibt, er spielt Battle Mercy.
Battle Mercy, GTF.
Ich warte mal auf euch.
Die Orisa hier ist YOLO-Style, oder?
Wird nicht gewartet.
Geht's direkt rein.
Ja, ja, er fliegt runter.
Oh, nee. Keine runtergefallen.
Puh.
Die Diva, lol.
Na?
Ducken spammen wie die Großen.
Das können sie.
Komm, Orisa, auf.
Nein, da.
Das ist ja schlimm. Will keiner rein.
Ich switch nächste Runde mal auf Ana oder sowas.
Irgendwas mit ein bisschen mehr Heal.
Ich dachte, wenn wir das jetzt eine Weile aussetzen,
erbarmt sich vielleicht einer, mal Support zu spielen.
Ja, mit ein bisschen Glück, ne?
Oh mein Gott.
Das war die beschissenste Pulsbombe.
Ich hab's gesehen.
Ich hab gleich wieder Ult.
Aber die Koordination ist ja wieder absolut killer.
Eigentlich wollte ich den da retten, den Junkrat,
aber der wollte nicht.
Ja, ich spiel Ana nächste Runde.
Das wird sonst nix hier mit Lucio Single Support.
Ah! Da geht was.
Da geht was.
Was ist denn? Die kommen jetzt rechts rum.
Da kann ich sie alle runterkicken.
Wahnsinnig.
Nice, 3-1. Der Roadhog muss gebasht werden.
Der ist runtergetroppt.
Bzw. wird von unserer Orisa runtergezogen.
War das eine Pulsbombe?
Nice.
Schön ins Gesicht.
Achtung, der kommt hinter dir. Die flanken hinter dir rum.
Hinter dir kommt ein McCree.
Spawnrape.
90%.
McCree pusht vorne raus.
Die pushen auf den Spot.
Mach die Pulsbombe weg.
Auto weg.
Kommt her Leute.
Fleisch!
Das ist بع auf der Game mit der Failpool Spawn.
Easy win!
Easy Clap.
Wir haben uns absichtlich so angestellt.
Wir wollen uns hier einspielen.
Wir mussten uns das Leben ein bisschen schwer machen.
Hm.
Luciosolohilometer.
Funktioniert.
General Slain.
Warum soll ich switchen?
Ich war gestern Nacht online bis irgendwie eins oder so und jetzt wieder, tja, ich hab Urlaub.
Nix damit switchen, du bist, wahrscheinlich hast du alles Gold und alle Gegner gekillt.
Insofern, selbst wenn du nicht alles Gold hast, geht es dir um die wichtigen Kills und nicht um Hauptsache Max Dammit.
Also ich hatte die Runde sechs Pulsbomben, sechs Stück.
Ja, das spricht dafür, dass du nicht switchst, sondern der McCree könnte switchen zum Beispiel.
Ich geh mal auf den Spot heilen.
Fuck, fuck, die Orisa hat Fortify-Gedöns angehabt.
Flieg, Lord of the Horde, flieg, flieg, flieg, flieg.
Ist der runtergefallen? Nope.
Schade.
Unlock, ich geh drauf.
Also ich hab keinen Support, ne?
Ey, ich hab die Pulsbombe geworfen, da wurde ich gestunt, dann war sie weg.
Und Urkund auch, echt geil.
Der Lucio hat immer viel.
Och, jetzt wieder voll.
Ey, eben des Todes.
Was?
Ocarino.
Genji geht auf den Punkt.
Nice.
Der will nicht, dass ich ihn heile, auch gut.
Haben wir keinen Bock drauf.
Wir haben überhaupt keine gescheiten Fights, ich krieg keine Ulti.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Ich bin hier ganz schön, ganz schön weit vorne, ziemlich.
Fuck, eigentlich dachte ich, der stirbt jetzt.
Ich heb die Ulti.
Ich nehme die Ulti auf.
Nein.
Chat hat, Chat hat gerade gesagt, du sollst, ich nehme gerade nichts auf, du sollst mal
Tracer wie Sun spielen, das wollen die Leute jetzt sehen.
Und dann fällt da die Brücke runter.
Oh Mann, Leute, jetzt kann ich nicht mal gescheit ulten, weil alle weg sind.
Ich ulte dich jetzt.
Mercy hat geultet.
Innen drinne.
Shit.
Und ich kann nichts machen, ist alles voll, sogar ein Reinhardt drinnen, der um sich swingt, aber 9-9-0, komm, einen Fight noch gewinnen und easy win.
Doch, LeronDG, ich bin Diamant, ich habe auf meinem Main-Account nicht mehr gespielt seit Season 3, deswegen habe ich mir extra einen neuen Account gemacht.
Das ist kein Smurf im eigentlichen Sinne.
Ich dachte, man kommt da rüber, ich wollte es mal ausprobieren.
Ich habe gerade vollgesrowt, also wenn ich jetzt verliere, ich war dran schuld.
Ich wollte gucken, ob man über den Abgrund ohne Speedboost rüberkommt.
Ich kann dir sagen, es funktioniert nicht.
Ich bin da.
Kommt raus, kommt raus, ich will euch runterwerfen.
Nein, huge, huge Tire.
Was eine Runde, ey.
Lose your solo heal, neues Meta.
Das hat auch gepasst.
In dem Moment, wo ich gesagt habe, das ist...
Oh, was ist denn das?
Ich wollte das doch irgendwas Dummes in den Chat schreiben, weil ich muss mich zurückhalten.
Du weißt doch, wie das ist, wenn man streamt, da muss man Vorbild sein.
Dann wirst du gebannt.
Genau.
Danke für die Follows.
Ich habe den Follows-Out ein bisschen leiser gestellt, das heißt, es kann sein, dass ich es manchmal nicht mitkriege.
Falls ich irgendwie eine Donation oder sowas verpasse, dann spammt mich mal bitte voll.
Ey, das sollte.
Das sollte nicht sein.
Siehst du raus?
Ja.
Vorbild und Twitch, Leute.
Neue Season heute.
Huge.
Huge, schau mal, ich noch nicht ganz, noch nicht ganz.
Ich muss sagen, der Smurf kommt gerade echt gelegen, so zum Üben, aufwärmen.
War das gut.
Ich muss ja sagen, bei mir ist es ja nicht so wirklich ein Smurf.
Ich habe es so lange nicht gespielt.
Wenn ich mir überlegt hätte, ich würde jetzt quasi Main Account spielen, quasi so...
...Master- und GM-Games reinkommen, ey, meh, da hätte ich echt keine Haft drauf.
Vor allem wirst du ja als Mercy-Main degradiert.
Vor allem müsste ich wahrscheinlich...
Na, wobei, nee, in Grandmaster nicht.
In Grandmaster gibt es genug Mercys.
Grandmaster gibt es genug Mercys.
Es ist anscheinend nur auf Diamond das Problem, dass es keine Mercy-Mains gibt.
Ja, alle wollen so hoch, ne?
Alle wollen so klein.
Schrecklich, schrecklich.
Hast du ja schon wieder gesehen, keiner Support gespielt für die Runde.
Naja, das kann man ja nicht blamen.
Wir hatten einen DPS und einen Support gespielt.
Nee, wir konnten da nichts machen.
Iconworld.
Darf ich jetzt vielleicht mal Proton spielen?
Ich guck mal, was die anderen so am Start haben.
McCree, Genji, 30 Stunden.
Quasi 30 Stunden Genji.
Wir haben Mercy-Main.
Batlogs, 12 Stunden.
Mercy, Lucio-Main.
Der darf Mercy spielen.
Ähm...
Später.
Torbjörn.
Was?!
Oooooooooooooooooohhhhhh....
Lüle.
Ist das hier die Troll-Elo?
Der Torb, der Attack-Torb.
Die Fl-
Was is' da, was is' da im Chat schon wieder los?
Wer da schon wieder getiltet, bevor die Runde losgeht, seh ich das richtig, ja?
Spiel jetzt Anna.
Es reicht schon.
Wenn im Ready-Room so...
So'n Throw-Pick nimmst da.
Ja.
Zack und weg.
Don't worry.
I can heal. Mal gucken ob er das macht. Ja, er heilt mit Armor. Ja, der trollt mit seinen
komischen Armor Packs. Also, ich guck mal wie es mit Anna geht, ansonsten muss ich halt
wieder die... switch to Mercy, hey, er hat Mercy geswitcht. Symmetra Balls. Oh, wo ist
das Schild hin? Das Schild ist weg. Dieses Gespamme, mir geht es so auf den Sack. Oh
ja. Kommt Leute, lasst euch raushooken. Hookerino. Oh, naja. Man kann es ja mal probieren. Ich
mach das Schild kaputt. Schild weg. Mercy weg. Glaube ich nicht. Oh. Ich kann da gerade
wirklich durch. Soldier. Soldier ist weg. Passt, also wenn wir jetzt noch eine Weile
so machen, dann haben wir die gleich... So weit ausgedünnt die Gegner. WTF?
Warum? Warum stirbt doch nichts? So, genug gestorben, oder nicht? Ja, jetzt halt anschluss nicht.
Vorher gut und dann... fuck, alle tot von uns. Bad Company 3 hyped. Ich hoffe echt, dass
das wird Bad Company 3. Ich habe wenigstens einen Chunk gehört. Ich gucke mal ob ich den gehookt kriege.
2 Ulti. Schild weg. Scheiß-Ulti. Oh, heal. Ich mach denen so viel Damage. Das gibt das doch nicht. Ist ein bisschen mies, das keiner richtig bringt.
Ich hab die Symmetra auf mir drauf, fuck.
Und ich werd zugespammt.
Symmetra ist tot.
Oben ist immer noch der Junkrat.
Die Mercy ist links.
Oh, ich fliege.
Das ist mega zum Kotzen, dieses Höhengespam.
Sag mal...
Oh, Leute.
Was ist denn? Warum geht denn da nix?
Warum geht hier nix?
Das ist ja der Wahnsinn.
Geht nicht vorwärts.
Willkommen.
Abgelenkt.
Wir dürfen nicht zu schnell climben.
Das geht auch nicht.
Wir sind nicht so schnell geclimbt.
Das sind einfach diese Low-Skill-Helden.
Ich komm halt nicht durch hier gescheit.
Ach, perfekt.
Los, easy.
Wenigstens Damage gemacht.
Ich könnte mir mal ein gescheiter
gescheites Fadenkreuz jetzt für Roadhog einstellen.
Ich guck mal, ob einer Schildtank pickt.
Ja, mach ich das.
Ähm...
Wie findest du Moira?
An sich find ich's vom Konzept gut,
dass du so einen Held hast,
der quasi so eine Ressource hat zum Ausgeben
und quasi dann durch Damage
wieder quasi sowas wie Mana hat.
Wenn man's so will bei Moira.
Ich hab grad mega den...
Unluckiest-Hooked-Ever abbekommen.
Glaubst du nicht?
Was denn Unlucky-Hook?
Mhm.
Weißt du noch dieses eine Video,
was ich dir ja geschickt hab
mit diesem Most-Impressive-Roadhog-Hook, oder?
Nee, kann ich mich da mal dran erinnern.
Wo ich McFree gehookt hab
und dann auf einmal einen Zenyatta hatte?
Da war irgendwas, ja.
Genau, das ist gerade mir auch passiert.
Also ich find Moira vom Konzept her,
um jetzt nochmal drauf zurückzukommen,
finde ich das gut.
Ich...
Mir fällt schwierig,
Moira gerade so ein bisschen in
Coms zu sehen.
Ich mein, Dallas hat's probiert
auf Junkertown
mit einer Comp,
die quasi darauf aufbaut
mit Moira
und sie haben gegen Bastion-Strat
einfach nur auf den Sack gekriegt.
Du hast halt nur
eine gewisse Anzahl von Helden,
die für Close-Range-Heal in Betracht kommen.
Also wenn du jetzt sowas,
wenn du jetzt sowas wie
Genji-Tracer und so spielst,
irgendwas, was du ein bisschen über Range heilen musst,
das...
Das ist ja auch schwierig mit Moira.
Aber wie gesagt,
ich bin da auch nicht mehr sonderlich gut in dem Game.
Deswegen...
Vielleicht findet ja einer was Gutes
und Moira ist übelst OP.
Doomfist, ey.
Dümmster Held aller Zeiten.
Die haben Symmetra, Attack-Symmetra.
Echt, der Stein?
Wird zurückgebaut.
Der ist fast tot, der Doomfist, alter!
So, jetzt ist Doomfist aber weg.
Ich muss mich heilen.
Wieso unser Heiler?
Oh nein.
Gute Frage.
Haben wir gar keinen?
Symmetra ist ver...
Äh, die...
Die...
Jetzt haben sie aber einen.
Jetzt haben sie einen Tele.
Das ist wieder lächerlich hier.
Was ist das für eine...
... für eine Runde?
Was ist da nochmal?
Tanerang?
Ähm...
Was haben wir?
3.000...
3.250 oder sowas?
Ah, die hatten doch übelst einen Trollkack dabei wieder.
Gut, next game.
Ich zieh uns mal raus.
Oder hast du irgendwas, was du gucken willst?
Nö, nö.
Ah, ich bin zuversichtlich,
dass wir einen Master packen.
Es sei denn, das läuft so wie in diesem Game.
So.
Jetzt machen wir das Aufwärmen weg.
Jetzt haben wir uns aufgewärmt.
Ups.
Win.
Loss.
0-0.
Ne, eigentlich 1-1, oder?
1-1.
1-1 hatten wir.
1 gewonnen, 1 verloren.
Hello, no second plan.
Das stimmt, die Bälle von Moira sind das einzige, was...
...was man als OP irgendwie ansehen könnte.
Aber Moira hat allgemein Schwierigkeiten,
gerade seinen Platz zu nehmen.
Ihren Platz zu finden.
Außer, dass jeder Moira spielt.
Ich werde Schild picken, falls keiner Schild pickt.
Was spielt denn dieser Gavass sonst?
Mercy.
Gavass ist Mercy-Main.
Jetzt haben wir zwei Mercy-Mains, weißt du?
Okay, dann bleib ich doch mal Roadhog.
Morris, ja, geb ich dir recht.
Da geb ich dir voll und ganz recht.
Boah, hast du das schon?
Das ist gut, aber wir müssen jetzt noch mal am Ende gucken.
Ja, wir spielen jetzt noch die verdammte Folge.
Wir spielen jetzt noch in der zweiten Halbzeit.
Wir spielen jetzt noch die zweite Halbzeit.
Ja, wir spielen jetzt noch die dritte Halbzeit!
Also, wir spielen noch die dritte Halbzeit.
Wir spielen jetzt die dritte Halbzeit.
Ja gut.
Ne, wir spielen nach dem Wortspiel.
Also, wir spielen nach dem Wortspiel.
Dann können wir jetzt hier unten so ein bisschen rausّln.
Ja, so schnell wir in der 39.
Ja, wir kommen jetzt hier rein.
Okay, wir gehen jetzt rein.
Ja.
In der 42.
Das heißt, er möchte anscheinend gerne Symmetra und Moira spielen, keine Ahnung warum wir
drei Supports haben.
Aber das geht.
Auf dem Punkt ist das jetzt zwar nicht optimal, aber das geht ja, sofern Moira und Symmetra
auch noch ein bisschen mitmischen.
Was macht der Reinhold da in der Ecke?
Keine Ahnung.
Da stehen.
G-Baiten.
Oh, voll in die Saria gefeedet, ja.
Wo wird geschnipsert?
Oh mein Gott, lass mich doch nicht alleine hier.
Help.
Wieso pusht denn keiner?
Weiß nicht.
Die Saria ist gut aufgeladen.
Sag mal, kann ich mal irgendeinen Hook heute treffen?
Ich bin vorne mit dir.
Okay, Hook müssen wir nochmal üben heute.
Mercy.
Hab sie.
Hook müssen wir nochmal üben, ich habe sagenhafte 0%.
Okay.
Was heißt, ich habe noch keinen Hook getroffen?
Yeah.
Darf die Saria nicht so sehr feeden?
Wenn die da reingehen, werden sie...
Mercy, jawoll.
Rekt, würde ich mal sagen.
Rekt.
Sniper, linke Seite.
Triple Headshot.
Wo ist er hin?
Knapp, knapp.
Ich hätte ihn fast gehabt.
Der geht bestimmt wieder oben ans Fenster.
Ich versuche, gucke, ob ich ihn raushopen kann.
Jutsch, Hook.
Ist gut.
Wo ist er?
Oben links.
Oben links ist er.
Ich gucke mal, ob der runter geht.
Wenn der runter geht, hole ich ihn mir.
Der ist schon.
Der ist schon down?
Er ist down.
Stimmt, die Symmetra.
Jetzt kommen sie mit einer Pharah an.
Bleiben wir der Ulti.
Pass auf, pass auf, pass auf.
Rechts drinne.
Ja, die D.Va ist noch links drinne.
Die können wir noch killen.
Ich glaube, die ist hochgegangen.
Hat sie sich gesniped?
Ja, die D.Va ist noch links drinne.
Die können wir noch killen.
Ich glaube, die ist hochgegangen.
Hat sie sich gesniped?
Ja, die D.Va ist noch links drinne.
Die können wir noch killen.
Ich glaube, die ist hochgegangen.
Ähhh, so groovy.
Hat sich gesniped?
Fuck, choke!
Ich hätte ihn killen können.
Lucio geht links durch.
Easy hold.
Was meinst du, Semmfischer?
Versteh ich grad net.
Freut ihr euch auch schon auf 6 Uhr?
Was ist denn um 6?
Ich bin wenig krank.
Ich war in der letzten Zeit vor allem auf DPS.
allem auf dps das richtige abstieg soll ich gerade so für für mccree und der
rest ist alles so naja das hat übrigens war ich merke es bei mir auch also vor
allem bei bei roadhog ich setze halt also nicht nur die hooks oftmals daneben
knapp sondern auch so die follow up shots weißt du da hast du was guckst
und denkst musst du killen musst du killen dann schießt du zweimal vorbei
und das ist weg ist halt kacke aber ein bisschen routine wieder kriegt dann
klappt das nach das winter wonderland update kommt heute okay das interessiert
mich ehrlich gesagt nicht so großartig ich finde sogar ein bisschen
fragwürdig geschmackssache ob es im rand die die weihnachts maps und so überhaupt
gespielt werden sollen weil sie sind halt schon anders von von belichtung her
und objekten und sowas ist nicht wirklich ein riesenunterschied ja kann
man sich darüber streiten an so besten die war
schon baut auf der rechten seite auf wo da rechts hinter dem kiosk hinter der
mauer oder bei uns da vorne irgendwo hinter der mauer ich mache einfach mal
mal so klein ich hoffe ich hab mal so in die rechts in die ecke der hoffnung ich
habe ich irgendwas mit der 400 zuschauer ich habe es nicht mal großartig auf
youtube gepostet und so hat vor allem wollen alle sehen wie wir master werden
heute
ab rang stream wobei noch ein paar wins dann und die haben zwei sniper hans und
weder rechts ist ach da ist ja ich gehe mal rechts durch westen linke seite
haben gehockt
was
trotzdem easy win
wettet eine 20 20 euro dass wir immer noch die sind am ende vom stream na ich
glaube das packen war dass das kriegen wir hin als kräuter ich erinnere mich
daran wenn wir fertig sind da ging er ab neues neues heil gucken das gab ja fast
nichts für dich gab es nichts ich habe schon wieder ein neues heil das gab ja
fast nichts
gut
trotzdem
14 punkte oder so
bei mir zucker 40
oder der leute wirst du ungefähr viel das gab oder wie gucke ich mich jetzt
wie wir hatten noch vorher waren noch
nee nee wart mal nee vorher hatten wir 25
vor 25
34 oder so okay gab doch mehr
aber was und was auch nicht
da
Ach, ihr mit eurem Smurf-Gelaber.
Für mich ist das kein Smurf.
Neuer Account, seitdem man sechs Monate nicht gespielt hat.
Und vor allem, wenn man sich anguckt,
was für kritische Sachen ich teilweise nicht treffe
und scheiße stehe und kacke baue.
Also, ich bin definitiv nicht da,
wo mein Main-Account eingerankt ist.
Deswegen spiele ich den ja auch nicht.
You time the Stoves mal wieder.
Ah, geht.
Solange wir keine 13 Minuten warten müssen.
Manche englischen Streamer.
Letzten Stream geguckt.
Irgendwie auch da Estimate-Time 45
und dann 13 Minuten rum.
Oh, da richtig gute Maps jetzt, ne?
Ich picke mal ganz schnell.
Was können wir machen?
Ich warte mal, was die anderen picken.
Okay, der Typ hat neun Stunden Bastion
diese Season gespielt.
Komm, wir machen jetzt
Bastion-Strat.
Aber das ist...
Was gibt das, wenn's fertig ist?
Das weiß man doch nicht.
Das würde uns überraschen.
Ich warte noch mal kurz ab, ja.
Ich geh mal in Voice rein, was wir schwätzen.
Wenn sie nerven, geh ich wieder raus.
Ich seh's kommen, dass ich Mercy spielen muss.
Nee, wir haben Mercy-Main.
Wir haben Mercy-Main.
Kannst du Bescheid sagen,
wieso die Welt in der Diamond-Rust-Chats ist?
Es geht eigentlich.
Die überlegen sich tatsächlich,
das ist eigentlich ne Taktik.
Jetzt natürlich die Frage.
Wir haben kein richtiges Schild für den Bastion.
Entweder will der Payload-Setup machen,
dann nehm ich nen Reinhardt,
oder ich nehm nen zweiten Support für Heal.
Ich spiel mal Sen.
Gucken, wie gut das funktioniert.
Je nachdem, was die Gegner haben.
Sen ist neben Lucio mein Lieblings-Support.
Weißt du, was richtig mies ist?
Ne Widowmaker, die Damage geboostet wird, permanent.
Und ein Sen, der das richtige Orb-Target hat.
Ja.
Alles am One-Shot-Nil.
So.
Generell, Sen ist so...
Übelst geil, einfach nur.
Also, wenn man was trifft,
was ich wahrscheinlich jetzt nach 6 Monaten nicht mehr wirklich mache,
aber gucken wir mal.
Au.
Zu viel Schild.
Bim, bim, bim, bim, bim.
Ich spamme aufs Schild.
Oh, oh, ich muss kurz decken.
Ja, Harambe, da kann ich dir nicht helfen.
Ich hab Shit gebaut.
Also, ich mach den ganz gut.
Ich mach den ganz gut.
Damage gerade.
Aber ich kann nicht wirklich weit vorne hin.
Oh, oh, oben ist ein McCree.
Ich versteck mich mal.
Weißt du.
Und da geh ich da hin.
Dass da nicht noch einer mal mit draufschießt.
Ich hab Ulti hier.
Warst du nicht mal Master?
Doch, bin ich ja noch.
Also, bin ich auf meinem Main-Account, aber
hab ich seit 3 Monaten nicht gespielt.
Oh, fuck.
Go, go, go, bashen.
Rechts, rechts, Junkrat drinnen.
Hier, ich werd gebound.
Ich brauch nen Rats.
Ich bin hier oben auf der Brücke.
Kann man da nehmen?
Ich seh auch grad, ich hab Schrein-Drops, das tot ist.
Ich hab gleich wieder Ult.
McCree, McCree, McCree.
Flank, Zen.
Ich hab die Mercy.
Help!
Geht net.
Was ist denn das?
Das ist gar nichts, das ist Solo-Reihen-Gerenne.
Ey, ich hab gerade Performance-Drops, das tot ist.
Aber wissen geht nicht mehr.
Na, da ging wenig.
Versteh ich nicht.
Ist, ist Internet-Technik Telekom, oder?
Ne, ne, Frame-Drops.
Ich hab viel zu wenig FPS.
Also normalerweise halt ich 300 ohne Probleme.
Du kannst ja nach der Runde mal neu starten.
Also irgendwie,
sind wir nicht durchgekommen.
So überhaupt nicht.
Weil,
wieder,
Ja, ich hab relativ wenig genug.
fast, fast nicht rumgekippt ist.
Wenn der Bastion hat vielleicht jetzt auch nicht unbedingt dazu beigetragen,
dass er es besser funktioniert hat.
Ja, gucken wir mal.
Hämmern.
Wir hämmern.
Falls einer mit Tank spielt.
Kann doch sein, dass ich wieder alleine vorne stehe und sich keiner dafür interessiert.
Ey, das ist der Wahnsinn.
Das ist der Wahnsinn.
Was sagt denn eine FPS-Anzeige?
Ja, der droppt von 200 runter auf 90.
Das ist nicht wirklich spielbar.
Also vor allem Aim-Technik.
Triffst ja nichts gescheit.
Geht, geht der Chat noch?
Leute, geht der Chat noch?
Bei mir ist, hat sich das seit 6 Minuten nichts mehr getan im Chat.
Glaubt ihr, ich muss mal refreshen?
Chat ist kaputt.
Geht noch.
Ja, jetzt, jetzt geht's wieder.
Ey, statt nach der Runde mal den Rechner neu.
Also ich, keine Ahnung.
Ich, keine Ahnung.
Ja.
Ich kaufe mir demnächst eine Konsole und trete einen PC rein.
Kannste, Kamaste, machst du Top 500 Xbox?
Es gibt mir langsam auch voll auf den Sack sowas.
Ständig Probleme.
Ha, rekt.
Der Junker trifft gar nicht richtig.
Ich geh mal mit, ich geh mal mit unserem Harambe da runter.
Okay.
Da muss der Bastion, kommt da oben schon, selbst klar.
Wir sind ein bisschen, ein bisschen verteilt.
Die sind über uns.
Okay, wir sollten jetzt mal, ich brauch Heal.
Ja, jetzt werden die gemacht.
Mega verteilt.
Ich hab gleich einen Shatter.
War nix.
Huge Shatter war das.
Huge Shatter.
Score was mit Speed.
Absolute Huge Shatter.
Fat Big Slam.
Ah, irgendwie, das stimmt.
Frametrops ist wirklich, ist eh das Schlimmste.
Leute, nicht sterben, nicht sterben.
Ich setz euch Heal hin.
Hier.
Was, die fast tot hinten?
Oh, nee.
Puh.
Wir müssen an, wir müssen an Payload ran.
Klein weiser.
Vielleicht kriegen wir das noch ein bisschen gestallt.
Ja, Mei Ulti.
Was?
Nein, ich war nur dran.
C9.
Das hätten wir sogar halten können, ne?
Next.
Ja.
Willst du Leuchte an?
Okay.
Bis gleich.
So, Leute, hauen wir ne Runde Musik an.
Das können wir dann hier mal anmachen.
Geht gleich weiter.
Ich hoffe, die Telekom kackt heute nicht wieder ab.
Jetzt haben ganz viele Leute, wenn man im Internet guckt, so die gleichen Probleme.
Das, es ist nicht, es ist nicht die 24-Stunden-Trennung, die es früher bei DSL gab, sondern viele Leute
verlieren einfach jetzt bei VDSL, sagt das Modem, Synchronisierung verloren, kein Bock mehr.
Das Problem hab ich auch.
Ja.
Louis Vitor Stor
Fick auf Sportensor
Max hat auch seine negativen Seiten
Er kracht, keine Ahnung
Ich find's ganz lustig
Louis Vitor Stor
Wenn sie immer dabei machen müssen im Hintergrund
Nutboxen
Haftbefehl aus Nutbox
Oh je, das wär was
So, jetzt machen wir was Anständiges
Im Prinzip warten wir eh nur drauf, bis der E-Ax wieder da ist
Da ist er wieder
Ich hör da was im Hintergrund an Sounds
Jaja
Das ist aber toll, dass er mit
Discord-Kollegen
Der Disconnected dich gleich
Nicht, dass du denkst, du loggst jetzt im Discord aus
Machst einen Rechner an, es kriegt keiner mit, was du machst
Nee, nee
Ist da Instant
Der Wahnsinn, man
Ich denk mir so, wer spricht da?
What the fuck
Du hast noch nicht mal das Passwort eingegeben
Um ins Windows reinzukommen
Du hast das Haftbefehl verpasst gerade
Echt?
Ja, ist tragisch, ne?
Sag, wenn du wieder eingeloggt bist, dann lade ich dich ein
Oh
Also, wenn das jetzt wieder Frame drops
Oh, nee, dann lass was bleiben
Irgendwann hat's er schon
Achso, bist du wieder on?
Moment, ja, mach ich
Den ganzen Aufwand dahin plötzlich ausblenden
Go, go
Ey, wir haben Instant Game gefunden
Lul
Und gleich bester Spielmodus
Die Zockermaus ist bei uns
Na dann
Bestimmt Mercy Main
Genji Main
Genji?
What the fuck
Los geht's, man
Ich will mal wieder Ogisra spielen
Schon lagern immer
Ich mach's mal von abhängig
Was wir gleich für Supports kriegen
Was haben wir für Supportspieler?
Äh, Eisgurke
Nee, Einsgurke spielt Moira
Äh, ansonsten
Nicht wirklich
Wir haben kein Tank
Spiel, na, wir haben
Was ist denn das wieder?
Hahaha
Okay, wir haben aber eine andere
Egal, YOLO
Äh
Naja
2CP, Resident Sleeper
Aber das T-Victus
Sein Lieblingsspielmodus ist
Ich bin ja auch fast vom Glauben abgefallen, ne
Und wie gesagt, er meinte das ernst
Du musst jetzt nur noch überlegen, welcher
Mein neuer Lieblingsspiel
Ja, das Ganze ist eigentlich untragbar, oder?
Ja
So was geht nicht mehr
Gar nicht
Musste gleich
Gleich Abo kündigen
Dis-Abo, nicht De-Abo
Gibt die Leitung tatsächlich keinen 1080p-Stream her?
Ähm, doch
Allerdings das Bitrate-Limit von Twitch gibt keinen
1080p-Stream wieder, äh, her
Macht das Schild kaputt, Leute
TF, wie schnell das Schild kaputt ist
Genji hinten
Ahhhh
Fuck
Ben, jetzt kommt der Bam-Tier
climb
Kletter
Kabumm
Scheiße, wir haben keine Mercy
Die wollen durch
Roadhog ist links durch
Ne, Da konnte ich nicht viel machen
Ich hab aber Bongos am Start
Ich mach jetzt die exquisite stretch
Die hab ich mir abgeguckt aus einem stream
Das ist easy win
So was burger
Jack look ?
education
Best Sanskrit
Sh forskut
Does君
어떻게
R Hidden
Photos
Vergangens meaning
Vongerechter
Abzug
Ich Tradie ora
Easy win.
Prost, Trads.
Warum sterben wir eigentlich?
Wir können gar nicht sterben.
Wir haben sogar Damage Boost.
Broncos sind weg.
McCree ist weg.
Prost, Trads.
Siehste, Leute.
Stream gucken lohnt sich.
Haben die einen Roadhog oder sowas?
Ne.
Doch, haben sie.
Sag mal, wo die langkommen.
Kommen die unten Haupt?
Mitte, Mitte.
Nein, durch.
Nein.
Schönen Roadhog.
Weiß nicht genau, wo.
Irgendwo links.
Irgendwo links habe ich einen Roadhog gehört.
Den können wir chasen.
Ich glaube, der ist hier noch.
Draußen, der Roadhog.
Hat sich zumindest so angehört.
Bin dran, ja.
Ach, der ist bei euch.
Der ist wieder auf dem Spot.
Ne, und wo ist er?
Draußen.
Draußen, okay.
Ich konnte es nicht genau zuordnen, von wo das kommt.
Ich gehe wieder da hoch.
Das ist eine ganz gute, ganz gute Pose.
Roadhog oben links bei mir.
Bist du allein da oben?
Oh.
Puh.
Und why?
Ich komme mal was mit Speed zurück.
Ich bin auf dem Spot.
Oh, fuck.
Hätte klappen können.
Defense Matrix war alle.
Hoffentlich kontestet das jemand.
Naja, ne.
Das sieht nicht so aus.
Kontest.
Ich bin gleich wieder da.
Gleich wieder da.
Ey, ich habe den McCree gerade in den Headshot gedrückt.
Ich habe so das Gefühl, das liegt da im Desolator.
Oh, sorry.
Ich hab ihn.
Anders kann es nicht mehr sein.
Äh, hast du jetzt immer noch Frametrops?
Ne, ne.
Gott, nice.
Aber immer noch diesen Paketverlust.
Und auf zwei Leitungen, das ist halt unwahrscheinlich.
Noo.
Haben wir den Mercy?
Ne.
Haben wir nicht?
Ne, wir hatten, ne, Ana hatten wir eben.
Bumm.
Der Reinhard kommt unten lang.
Unten links ist irgendwas.
Der McCree ist unten links.
Ich brauch mal Heal oben rechts.
Vorsicht wegen dem Shatter, ne?
Ich weiß nicht, von wo der McCree... McCreed.
Huge!
Ich bin alleine gegen den McCreed draußen. Das ist doof.
Nein! Nicht mich!
Die kommen wieder. Wir sollten zurück.
So sieht die Leute aus.
Fast down der Reinhardt.
Ich brauch Heal!
Alter, ich hab gerade getroffen wie ein Boss. Das glaubst du nicht.
Ja, irgendeiner muss ja was kennen.
Jetzt hab ich natürlich Shadowplay ausgeschaltet.
Kannst du nicht OBS, Replay Buffer oder sowas machen?
Wenn Shadowplay grad nicht funktioniert.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, ob's funktioniert. Ich hab's einfach mal vorsorglich ausgeschaltet.
Kannst die Highlights speichern.
Da hast du dann irgendwie nur 30 Sekunden. Weiß nicht, wie lang die sind.
Na, mal gucken, wie das klappt.
Also, wenn da kein Play of the Game dabei ist, dann bin ich echt beleidigt.
Nee, wir hatten keine Mercy. Sonst hätte ich gesagt, einfach ein paar Razzis und gut ist. Play of the Game.
Ja. Die fühlen sich auch so toll an, ne?
Kannst du noch früher dran erinnern, wenn du den größten Scheißplay gemacht hast?
Oder wenn die Mercy den größten Scheißplay gemacht hat, irgendwie sinnlos reingeflogen hat, Leute gerätzt, obwohl du eigentlich respawnen müsstest und so.
Play of the Game. Hat zwar nichts gebracht, war total useless, aber Play of the Game.
Das war damals echt, das war zu viel des Guten. Das wollte halt auch keiner sehen.
Das war echt zu viel des Guten, ja.
Weiß noch, die Foren-Complains und so auf Reddit.
Ah, Mercy, Play of the Game, mach das weg, bitte.
Am Anfang, beste Play of the Game am Anfang war immer noch diese AFK-Torp-Play of the Games.
Weißt du so, Turret, so, ich steh jetzt in der Ecke, bohr in der Nase, Play of the Game.
Nee, nee, nee, gestorben, gestorben, aus dem Torp rausgelaufen.
Ach, gestorben, ja, noch besser. Gestorben, Turret rastet aus. Hinter uns ist ein Torp, Turret.
No.
Reinhardt.
Nice, du.
Ich will mit der Flash springen.
Ich kann da, ich will da nicht alleine vor jetzt.
Bin schon drin.
Ich muss weg.
Die Orisa ist direkt hier davor.
Hab sie. Mercy ist auch weg.
Fliegen die Hooks hier, 100% der Hook ist hier. Easy.
Nach zwei Hooks.
Ähm, was macht unsere Diva da, wenn man fragen darf?
Wollten die respawnen? Wollten die respawnen im Mech? Ja, das kann sein.
Okay, wir gehen oben rechts.
Immer noch Torp, ey.
Der hat bestimmt auch einen Core jetzt. Muss einen Grund haben. Oder kurz davor.
Warte mal kurz, bis ich wieder Hook hab.
Wieso werde ich nicht geheilt?
Was?
Mach weg.
Ich bin da.
Gewinnen, bitte.
Dachte mir, ich kann sie schon wegblasen jetzt, aber nope.
Warum wurde Hook plus One-Shot vom Roadhog abgeschwächt? Weil es OP wie Sau war.
Und es war auch nicht sonderlich spaßig, dagegen zu spielen.
Okay.
Ja, don't know. Mehr kann ich nicht machen.
Ich bleib mal hier stehen.
Und warte, bis ihr wieder da seid.
Am Pick.
Oh, ihr geht links, wie ich sehe.
Das hat überhaupt keinen Sinn, was wir hier machen gerade.
Ne, nicht wirklich.
Yes.
Achso.
Ich kann da oben schön rein-spammen.
Okay, nice, nice, nice. Jetzt gehen wir.
Torp kommt hoch.
Wo? Ach, da ist der Fuck-Tunnel, der ist da oben.
Scheiße.
Ja.
Ist ein bisschen scheiße. Wir haben keine Leute, die auf den Spot gehen und gut machen.
Ich bin immer halb down.
Das ist schlimm.
Ich muss mich mal verpissen.
Gleich wieder oben.
Geht halt nicht vorwärts.
Ist halt scheiße. Ich mach einen Pick und dann wird eh wieder gut.
Ich switch jetzt Mercy, easy.
Dann gewinnen wir.
Aber wir haben nur Solo hier.
Monatspflicht.
Torp ist weg.
Ich haupt die Torpen runter.
Reinhard ist fast tot.
Äh.
Okay.
Auch gut.
Easy.
Einmal durchgekommen.
Das war eben keiner auf dem Spot, ey.
Einmal durchgekommen, gewonnen.
Mein Play of the Game.
Ach, fuck.
Ey, du kannst heilen.
Ey, du kannst Highlights gucken.
Guck Highlights hier bei dir ingame.
Guck mal, das müsste da sein.
Kannst Highlights gucken.
Da ist es.
Hanamura.
Mal gucken, welches das ist.
Jetzt werden sie gereckt.
Kannst mir ja nicht mit angucken.
Das wäre doch auch mal was. So ein Kinomodus für das Game.
Und? Hast du geowned?
Ja.
Nice.
Das war genau das mit dem, wo der Headshot nicht, äh, kein Headshot war.
Keine Ahnung.
Headshot.
Kann ich queuen?
Vielleicht mal McCree.
Ich muss mal die Win-Loss.
Jawoll.
Noch ein 2CP.
Endlich.
Endlich können wir mal den besten Spielmodus genießen, richtig.
Wenigstens haben wir eine Mercy dieses Mal.
Ich spiele mal wieder Symmetra.
Mal warten, was die anderen picken.
Falls Ben Schild dabei ist, muss man wieder Symmetra spielen.
Solcher.
1904.
Nein, ich glaube, das wollen Super Blizzard nicht.
Die wissen ja auch viele Sachen.
Also vielen Sachen ist denen auch, sind denen garantiert klar.
Ist das nicht die Mercy vom letzten Game?
War die nicht im anderen Team?
Oder bin ich jetzt blöd?
Ja, kann sein.
Ja, ja, kann sein.
Kann sein.
Kommt mir vom Namen bekannt vor.
Zellfetz.
Yo.
Tippmann2K.
Das ist wie Ipmann.
Ich muss jetzt hier ganz, ganz fest sein.
Ich muss jetzt hier ganz, ganz versteckten Turrets.
Was ging die Genji-Mains hier?
Haben wir was mit Schild?
Ja, Orisa.
Das ist doof, da sehe ich nichts.
Ja, ich sehe auch nichts, wenn die Orisa die ganze Zeit so rumhampelt.
Oh, hier ist irgendwo ein Raider.
Oh, fu!
Was war das denn?
Hä?
Okay.
Das war bestimmt...
Da ging er ab.
Der hat den Gang gesichert.
Zahlrechte.
Easy.
Du hast das schon.
Geh reikt!
Wenn ich wieder da bin, muss ich noch einen Hit machen, dann gibt's Schild oder Tele,
je nachdem.
Wenn wir alle leben, mache ich Schild.
Ja, wäre wahrscheinlich das Sinnvollste.
Das haben wir.
Ja, so braucht man keinen Teleport mehr.
Oh, fuck.
Ich habe ihn nicht ausgestraft bekommen.
Jetzt habe ich Schild.
Oh, das war dumm.
Das war richtig dumm.
Nice.
No sleep.
Nein.
Oh, fuck.
Ich habe ihn nicht ausgestraft bekommen.
Jetzt habe ich Schild.
Oh, das war dumm.
Das war richtig dumm.
Nice.
No sleep.
sleep ich war mal doch ein tele hin schrecklich gerade alle tele der tele
rettet ja selber noch ein spock gehen auf orisa rennt perfekt ich nehme was
anderes ja mein schnick so richtig gegen sein
fast down der reaper ich geb dir einen ort bald ich sehe der reinheit schätter
der sie ist bei dem richtig an der guckt schon quasi so ich glaube ich nehme
irgendwas mit speed man also wenn jetzt noch jemand auf den spot kommt dann
haben wir noch eine chance ja ich probiere es probier's probiert
ich bin drauf
überleben überleben gott sei dank das war der mega lucky
frank ich habe beide supporter rausgekriegt
ich muss mal aufladen ich brauche noch kurz für das auto gehen
rechts rum
aber da
Schrrange schlug
dein kopf
wo easy
im
Meister
J Cover
folgt
jetzt
Dissert concentrate
са
Ich wollte die Flashbang über ein Reinhardt-Schild werfen, dann kommt gerade diese fliegende Plattform und fängt das Ding voll ab.
Das ist schadsträmmig.
Weich im Arsch.
Ja, ich sag mal, kann auch mal scheiße werden.
Wir sind ja Diamond, ne?
Nicht umsonst.
Genau.
Nicht umsonst Diamond.
So ein Schild wäre nice.
So was Reinhardt-mäßiges zum Beispiel.
Das ist...
Ich mach mal einen Reinhardt, ne?
Mhm.
So ein bisschen was haben.
Also hier on-Stream, ich lerne quasi im Stream Main-Tank spielen.
Vorher noch nie gemacht.
Also auch gestern schon.
Übelst verkackt am Anfang.
Es waren auch ein paar ganz nette Plays, fand ich gestern noch dabei.
Aber alles in allem ist mein Main-Tank-Play jetzt so wirklich nichts, was man groß vorzeigen kann.
Bist du in dem Firestrike ausgewichen?
Ja.
JM, du bist JM.
JM, easy.
Ich hab's sogar gemacht.
Ich hab's sogar in Firestrike getroffen, ne?
Der Junkrat hat's auf mich abgesehen.
Keine Slow.
Ich glaub, der Junkrat ist noch rechts drinnen.
Nein, ich bin in der Falle.
Der Junkrat kommt jetzt von hinten ran.
Oder auch nicht.
Main-Tank-Play ist hier.
Geht der Chat noch, Leute?
Oh, seid ihr alle eingeschlafen?
Mein Schild wird gespammt.
Wie sau.
Also, ich bin hinten.
Komm, push rein, push rein.
Wir sind abgelenkt.
Oh.
Oh Mann.
Jetzt kommt der Junk aus dem Spawn.
Was ist er?
Oh, ich muss mich fressen.
Wow.
Hilfe.
Stream mit 160p anschauen.
Nice.
Ich sehe nur Pixel.
Warum schaust du den Stream mit 160p an?
So, gefragt.
Bist du auch bei der Telekom?
Ich hab uns gerade am Abkacken wieder bei dir.
Budo Clown. Ja, ich bin gerade live.
Ich will nicht noch mal reinladen.
Aber komm.
Mal gucken, ob einer von denen pickt.
Wann wird das Overwatch-Winter-Update draußen sein?
Irgendjemand hat vorhin geschrieben um 6 Uhr.
Ich bin bei sowas immer total hinter Mond.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass es heute rauskommt.
Kommt das nicht am Donnerstag zu den Wartungsarbeiten?
Waren die nicht Wartungsarbeiten dienstags?
Also heute?
Keine Ahnung.
Ganz ehrlich, kein Schimmer.
Weißt du nicht.
Ich bin bei solchen Events.
Ehe nie up-to-date.
Weil soviel wird ja auch nicht passieren.
Wahrscheinlich werden wieder die Server abkacken, weil 200.000 Leute einloggen wollen.
Gibt es eigentlich, ähm, mal eine Frage an den Chat.
Gibt es da schon Informationen, was da alles drin ist?
Wie sieht es mit der neuen Map aus?
Oder ist wieder, ist quasi dieses, was gab es denn letztes Weihnachts-Event?
Weißt du das noch?
Es gab Maps im Schnee und sowas, glaube ich, ne?
Ja, die sahen richtig geil aus.
Ansonsten Skins halt, ne?
Ist jemand hinter mir?
Flirt gefragt.
Äh, jein und ja.
Oh, nein!
Jetzt hat er mich geownt, der Reinhardt.
Jetzt hat er mich geownt.
Und sorry, du hast rechts geschoben.
Gebated hat er mich.
Hardcore jebated.
Was, Winston Boss jagt Mais?
What?
Ach, nicht Mais.
Mais.
Ich dachte jetzt an Mais.
Ihr wisst schon.
Das gelbe Zeug.
Maiso.
Habt ihr Mais gehalten?
Nee, re苦lo.
Whripammes-Maisen-Glasses.
Ja, wir hatten GameMix-Glasses noch nicht ge MaxIt gegen uns vor.
Neben-Exzellenzen haben Consumer主
AUFBAR wealthy und noch ein thiional Halt zu durchsetzen wirklich sich ausgewiesen sondern usar深 Schild sich weiter zu stationen lassen weil die suasantom können und ob man sich auf roster hatte ja aber ich bin selbst redden können dass immer das wichtigste rät dich selber versuchen auszurotten sich selber versuchen was zur
Das geht ist nicht gut Upperon!
Sehe ich das richtig? Wenn wir jetzt den ersten Punkt kriegen, haben wir es?
Das sollten wir schaffen in 6 Minuten 4.
Wenn du Reinhardt spielst, dann auf jeden Fall.
Albus bist.
Du arme Saule.
Ich muss Mercy spielen, ich muss Reinhardt spielen.
Ich muss die ganze Zeit Evinus spielen, worauf ich keinen Bock habe.
Wie fühlt sich das Leben als Flex an?
Eigentlich ist das geil.
Ich merke aber, dass ich halt total viele Helden einfach null kann.
Weißt du, wenn du dann vor Gegnern stehst und erst mal so richtig im Kopf merkst,
du Ratter, Ratter, Ratter, was muss ich jetzt machen, was muss ich jetzt machen, was muss ich jetzt machen?
Oh, zu spät.
Junkrat, Minen, nein.
Jetzt hat er es besser getimt, diesmal.
Symmetra.
Ja gut, die müssen 3 Stunden halten.
Ich gehe rein.
Über mir, über mir, über mir.
Ich musste weg, ich musste weg.
Nein!
Äh, die sind auf dem Punkt.
Das gibt es nicht.
Oh, die Symmetra ist fast tot.
Moment, wo sind die Leute?
Ich bin hinter dir.
Okay.
Das sollten wir haben.
Diesmal aber nicht Evin, ne?
Ne, diesmal gucken wir uns Play of the Game an.
Genau.
Da kommt Germany's Next Taimo im Fernsehen.
Next Taimo, ja.
Next Effect.
Taimo ist ja offiziell nur noch Flex.
Rekt.
Oh, Season High.
Oder?
Und?
Ja, fast, fast nach dem Match Season High.
Jetzt bist du noch 33 Punkte vor mir.
Wenn wir mal angefangen hätten, waren es 140 Punkte Unterschied.
Weißt du?
Easy.
Aber, so wirklich rausleveln, werden wir bis, bis hohe, hohe, hohe, hohe, hohe, hohe, hohe, hohe, hohe, hohe, hohe, hohe, hohe, hohe, hohe, hohe, hohe, hohe, hohe, hohe, hohe, hohe, hohe, hohe, hohe, hohe, hohe, hohe, hohe.
So.
Master, falls wir so weit kommen, nicht.
Man sind immerhin 500.
Oder ab GM sind es 250, ne?
Aber GM, das wird eh nix.
Das sagt niemand zu.
Zumindest aktuell nicht.
Ne, ich merke das selbst noch. Ich mache so viel
Scheiße, wo ich mir quasi in dem Moment,
wo ich es drücke, mir denke, ey, das war eine doofe Idee.
Ich muss mal kurz Chat gucken.
Freecore fragt,
Hey Max, also Hey Wobblos,
bitte schön, ja, Hey Wobblos und Chat.
Passt es, wenn mir
ein CPU-Kühler mit einer Höhe
165mm und ein Gehäuse
mit einer Breite für den Kühler
von Max 165mm hole?
Kommt drauf an, wie die das
fürs Gehäuse gemessen haben, ne?
So nach dem Motto, meinen die damit, dass was maximal reinpasst
oder das, wo halt noch schön Platz da dazwischen ist?
Ich würde einfach mal ein bisschen gucken
im Internet nach dem Gehäuse und nach dem Kühler.
Schwierig. Ich würde aus dem Bauch aus sagen,
es passt, aber
ich würde lieber vorher noch mal gucken.
Weißt du, wann du mal wieder programmierst?
Ähm, demnächst.
Wie gesagt, ich habe einen ganzen Monat Urlaub.
Deswegen mache ich auch so viele Videos und alles.
Ja, schöne.
Ich picke mal ganz schnell los, so dass keiner denkt,
ich muss Mercy spielen.
Hat mal eine ganz dumme Frage an euch.
Gibt es sowas wie externe SSDs?
Also sowas über USB, ja, klar gibt es.
Also man, für USB 2 würde ich es nicht nehmen.
Aber so USB 3, USB 3.1, USB C, ne, ach, USB-Standards.
Wer blickt da schon durch?
Hey, ist eine M2-SSD sinnvoll, wenn man schon eine normale SATA-SSD hat?
Preis-Leistungs-Verhältnis? Ne.
Also man muss bei SATA-SSD, äh, sorry, bei M2-SSD es eh unterscheiden.
Es gibt M2-SSDs, da sind quasi SATA-SSDs, aber halt über M2.
Oder es gibt NVMe-SSDs.
Die kommen auch in M2 rein.
Die sind quasi SATA-SSDs, aber halt über M2.
Die sind halt viel schneller, allerdings merkst du von diesem Speed letztendlich nichts.
Ich meine, es sind 3000 MB die Sekunde zu, keine Ahnung, 500 MB die Sekunde, aber das merkst du nicht.
Okay, ähm, was ist das, was ist das für eine Comp?
Die Verlierer-Comp.
Haha, sieht so aus.
Oh, ich hab, Moment, ich muss, ich muss, äh, äh, Statistik updaten.
Wir sind, wir sind, ja, ja, gleich, gleich, gleich.
3-1, 3-1.
Das ist, das ist ne, die, die Reuden-Comp, äh, das ist ja mal mies.
Läue.
Giant, dieses Gespamme, das ist so, No-Skill-Dummer-Scheiß.
Komm, sag, ja, ja, ja.
Ich nehm mir jetzt selber Junk.
Mach das, mach das.
Wow.
Der Junker hat spammt da unten rein, da können wir nix machen.
Ich geh mal oben lang.
Der Anso ist mega am Throne.
Der bleibt halt stehen, der bewegt sich nicht und schießt so.
Oh, Mr. Junker, den holen wir jetzt.
Wir haben ihn.
Mach doch mal diesen verkackten...
Uh.
Das gibt's nicht.
Ey, wenn wir das jetzt verlieren...
Das, wir, wir haben das echt verloren.
Schlimm, die sind einfach nicht umgekippt, die letzten paar Leute.
Huge, huge Kills.
Gleich wieder da.
Chyler gleich.
Jetzt mich heilen lassen.
Oh, jetzt ohne Heal, das ist kacke auf den Punkt, ja.
Ich hab gleich Ulti, ich hab gleich Ulti.
Wir haben zu wenig hier.
Das ist halt RIP.
Jupp.
Das ist RIP.
Bist du tot?
Mhm.
Danach werde ich wieder zum Mercy main.
Aber erstmal meine Ult raus hauen.
Leute, nicht verrecken alleine.
Ich, ich ulti jetzt.
Ich bin auf dem Spot, sonst keiner.
Moira ist auch auf dem Spot, ist down.
Ich bin bei dir, zum Heilen.
Tja.
Sache hier, Solo Luciometer.
Ja.
Ein Ding.
Der IceCold hat ja gerade festgestellt, dass man das komplett universal hier, Sprache-Overwatch spielen kann.
Mercy main ins GM.
Kein einzig deutsches Wort drinne.
Da hat er recht.
Brauchen wir nicht.
Overrated.
Hello.
Total overrated, deutsches Wort.
Komm, Mercy main.
Muss ich ja.
Also, Lucius Solo.
Defense ist kacke.
Also, wenn von denen keiner einen richtigen Hero pickt, dann heilst du die auch einfach nicht.
Musst du auch noch ankündigen, so im Chat, ne?
Was sind die eigentlich alle?
Genji main?
Anna main?
Ja.
Könnt ihr mal meine meisterhaften Mercy Plays bewundern jetzt.
Hast du die neue Pupke-Map inzwischen gespielt, Nö?
Ich hab Pupke auf dem neuen PC nicht mal installiert.
Jax, hast du die gespielt?
Die Wüsten-Map.
Ich hab fünf Minuten Testserver gespielt.
Ne, zwei Minuten.
Das hat so schlimm geleckt, ich hab's deinstalliert.
Perfekt.
Also alles beim Alten in Pupke, sozusagen.
Ey, ey, ich komm mal hoch zu dir.
Noch schlimmer.
Das leckt noch viel schlimmer.
Komm, wir gehen mal hoch und ich Damagebooste dich.
Wir machen wieder unsere Master-Taktik.
Ich halte dich einfach rechtsklickt, okay?
Und gut ist.
Okay.
Bleiben wir hier sneaky.
Mal gucken, was abgeht.
Ich mach mal den Stab aus.
So.
Jetzt.
Ich schieß einfach mit.
Ey, Moira, verpiss dich.
Alter.
Der soll doch da unten heilen, Mann.
Was macht der denn?
Wir sind rechts, Alter.
Bing.
Kein Dings benutzt?
Kein Deflect?
Ich weiß nicht.
Waaaah!
Was soll der jetzt halt machen?
Das war nix.
Hätte uns ein bisschen verpissen sollen früher.
Aber die Strats funktionieren einfach zu gut, als dass man sie nicht machen sollte.
Beste Strats.
Das war gerade der Hammer.
Also wenn wir noch einen Pick kriegen, gehen wir nochmal vor.
Erst den Headshot schießen und dann die Flashbang werfen.
So kippt man den Tracer.
Nicht andersrum.
Achtung, Achtung, jetzt schieß mit.
Nee, komm zurück.
Ich weiß ja eh nicht, warum die Bastion zocken.
Lass mich mal hochfliegen zu dir.
Wieder lang.
Aua.
Heilung.
Bing, Bing.
Der Reinhardt geht ran.
Äh, wir müssen runter.
Nee, bleib oben.
Ist nicht unsere Aufgabe.
Ich retz die mal.
Warum, warum kann ich nirgendwo hinfliegen?
Ist keiner da?
Nooo.
Mercy Place, lol.
Ich glaub, der da.
Richte Bronze-Place, ja.
Ich und Mercy, ne?
Ich komm, ich komm.
Ich komm, ich komm, ich komm.
Die Tracer hat Respekt-Schélen bekommen.
Aber auf den Feinsten.
No.
Ich hab, ich hab Ult.
Scheiße, da oben geht...
Die Tracer.
Die D-Inside, hätte ich nicht jetzt nochmals getrettet.
Huge Place.
Dsch-dsch-dsch-dsch.
das ist so spannend
nun fast immer so
die oben links auf dem Tag
Leid
ich muss setzen
rechts ist steht Prozent so wie warum
der Spass hier
ganz wichtig
so wissen
nach der Art und Weise
der Reinhard
ich habe heute
doch hinter der Wand
zu schmerzen ist
ich wusste nicht wo
es ist nämlich gar nicht mehr Kontexten hat kein Bock
Achtung kommst du zurück
ich halte hier durchgedrückt
ich müsste unser Reinhard heilen aber ich komme nicht hoch
euch fahrt
kann ich zu dir fliegen
weiter entdeckt ist nicht
aber ich gehe da nicht mehr hoch ich gehe nicht mehr hoch
immer wenn ich mich da oben hingehen zu denen ich mich der mit Buße nicht
permanent
Scheiße
das war eine Kräfte des Todes
alle Drillen
zwar ich auch viel zu wenig mittlerweile einfach mal gucken was haben die
Gegner für Helden und wie weit sind die wohl mit ihren Ultis
als noch früher war quasi kommt komplett in Übersicht wer was hat
von den Gegnern musst du alles
ja aber das liegt doch mittlerweile da
und das ist echt chaotisch geworden ist
als immer wirklich urteilen wer was hat
los beim Reinhard da sieht man es ja noch
als Schütze also bei sowas wie Saria und so geht's ja auch noch
als die Helden wo halt
unverändert sind so
so maßen
bei Sombra kannst du von ausgehen sie hat es eigentlich immer
nahezu immer
fliegst du mich an
hui
diesmal bleibt mir hier stehen
ich werde jetzt wahrscheinlich gleich gesniped von der Widow oder so
ja
während du von A nach B fliegen willst du
und dann bist du weg
oh jetzt sind wir aber offensiv da vorne dabei kann das sein
Firestrike
Firestrike und dann gedeift werden und verreckt oder sowas
also Genshi haben sie schon mal
ich drop dann gleich runter wenn hier zu viel Action wird
stell dich mal hinter mich nicht vor mich
ich geh runter
Rouge Place
oh man rennt doch nicht vor mir weg
ich seh dich nicht also
schau mich mal an
Junkart, ne?
ich bin oben
ich kann es
da ist ein wer anfigen wird
ich geh wieder hinter dich
ja Josef mir bleibt nichts anderes übrig
ja hau ab
ist gut Junkart, ist gut
ich gehe runter
ich drop runter und heil
da ist ein ... ist ein Winston rechts
pfiat mal die Tracer da unten
ach nee, die ist auf der anderen Seite
never mind
ich hab Ulti
ja super gemacht Reinhardt perfekt
Oh, ich wurde geschlitzt.
Ich wurde geschlitzt.
Oh Mann, ey.
Ich habe jetzt nicht verstanden, warum alle auf dem Heilgrund oben standen.
Ich glaube, das Problem war auch, dass welche unten quasi wieder vorgecharged sind, verreckt sind.
Ey, ich hasse es halt.
Du willst ein bisschen flanken gehen und dann versorgen wir die.
Warum ein Fight und gut ist.
Alter, was geht mit dir ab, Reinhard?
Ich bin mittendrin, das war eine ganz schön doofe Idee.
Scheiße.
Ist das so, ist das, wenn man seinen Team jetzt helfen will?
Ich komme mal mit irgendwas mit Speed wieder.
Aber dann haben wir keinen Heal.
Nein, komme ich nicht.
Das ist wieder so für den Arsch gewesen.
Wir sind jetzt, wir sind, der Reinhard ist over Extended, ich bin hinterher, wir sind verreckt.
Deswegen haben wir es verloren.
Ich hätte einfach sagen müssen, scheiß auf den Reinhard.
Oh, du bist übrigens schuld, sagt der Chat.
Darf ich was anderes spielen?
Das ist jetzt die Killer-Comp, die wir hier haben.
Oh Mann, ey, Diamond, Shit Talk.
Also ich finde, das hat immer der Wahnsinn.
Da wird geflamed.
Da sind sie alle ganz groß.
Da sind sie im Flam, sind sie alle ganz groß.
Oh, so dumm.
Warum bin ich dem Reinhard hinterher?
Also erstens, warum ist der Reinhard reingecharged in die Gegner?
Keine Ahnung, das war halt mega, ich auch nur.
Und warum?
Warum fliege ich auch noch hinterher?
Komm, weißt du was?
Wir brauchen jetzt keine Mercy.
Wir brauchen jetzt Lucio.
Damage boost.
Damage boost, ich mach das.
Nee, wir brauchen Lucio.
Du kriegst zu viel Speed boost.
Du musst ja den Rest nicht heilen.
Ist ja kein Problem.
Du musst nur mich heilen.
Komm, auf geht's.
Ist doch ein Deal, oder?
Machen wir.
Oh, wir haben noch eine Moira, jetzt ist alles gut.
Legst halt einen Stein auf deine rechte Maustaste und dann geht er schon.
Ach, Tommy, laber nicht.
Als wäre das kein Missplay gewesen, Ariolo reinzuchargen.
Ich bleib jetzt auf dir.
Okay, den musste ich jetzt mal heilen.
Der war so low.
Hinter mir ist ein Genji.
Ich bin gestunt.
Sorry.
Reine Mercy-Play ist legendär.
Wenigstens hatte ich immer meinen zweiten Spot.
Kommst du?
Ja, auf geht's.
Easy win.
Echt.
Ich geh runter.
Weißt du?
Ich bin Damage-Boost auf dir drauf.
Ich seh dich nicht mehr.
Ah, diese Resserei.
Ja, ich hab jetzt Ulti noch.
Ich warte, bis die wieder da sind.
Kommst du?
Hi.
Ich bin voll heal auf dir drauf, ne?
Oh, ich seh dich nicht mehr.
Ich seh dich nicht mehr.
Perfekt.
Die huge Mercy-Play ist wieder da.
Wieso muss ich eigentlich als...
Moment, der Winston.
YOLO.
YOLO, Winston.
Oh, da ist er.
Da ist er.
YOLO.
YOLO, Winston.
Okay.
Go, go.
Kannst du Damage-Boost bitte?
Ich mach den Winston.
Der Winston muss.
Nein.
Oh.
Oh, Mann.
Puh.
Moment.
Und wir haben noch nicht mal nen Drittel erwischt.
Ich sagte ja.
Bleib vom Winston weg.
Der bringt dich die ganze Zeit um.
Ich kann aber als Support nicht zugucken, wie alle verrecken vor mir.
Das halt ich nicht aus.
Da haben wir ne Ulti hier.
Ah, Wahnsinn.
Ja.
Ist gut.
Aber wir haben noch eins bis eineinhalb gescheite Angriffe.
Die Diva.
Nein, Diva nicht sterben.
Ja, das wird der letzte Fight.
Och, Mann.
Jetzt haben wir noch nicht mal ne Diva mit Auto am Start.
Ich bin auf dir.
Also.
Uh, kein Deflect.
Geil.
Nein.
Fuck, da konnt ich nix machen.
Äh, hallo?
Ich wollte dich retzen.
Geht nicht.
Ich darf dich nicht retzen.
Ging nicht.
Sorry, es wird gegamed wird.
Das musst du dir nochmal angucken im Stream, Clay.
Das ging nicht.
Ich hab davor gestanden.
Da am Anfang ist eh...
Ach, mein Retz ist nicht ab.
Äh.
Ja, Josen, mein Timing bei Mercy ist...
Natürlich wusste ich, dass mein Retz nicht ab ist.
Ja?
Oder er war ab.
Ich wollte den Ernst bloß nicht demoralisieren, quasi.
Er wollte so was quasi on fire bleiben.
Natürlich wusste ich das als langjähriger Mercy-Spieler.
Wir...
Warum?
Warum flamen die sich eigentlich permanent im Chat?
Wirklich permanent!
Du guckst in den Chat, irgendwie einer...
Cancel, shit, zack, alles voll, ja?
Tja.
Das müssen wir mal machen.
Nämlich kriegen wir dieses mal nen Tank und der Tank hält seinen Arsch unten.
Wir haben jetzt ne Orisa.
Der soll bloß wegbleiben, ey.
Ich will den hier oben nicht sehen, ohne Witz.
Ja, mit Josen hab ich früher viel gespielt.
Ja.
Aber wir müssen...
Ich dropp runter.
Pass auf, rechts, rechts, rechts, der D.Va.
Weiß nicht, wie ich den Zen gekillt hab.
Fu, fu, fu, fu, fu.
Ah, der D.Va ist auf mir drauf.
Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe.
Nice.
Ich retz den.
Oh, dann komm in die Mitte.
Damage boost.
Ey, Tracer, Tracer.
Jawoll.
Mercy basht Mercy.
So muss das sein.
Ha.
Verlieren können wir jetzt schon mal nicht mehr.
Ja.
Gibt nur noch draw.
Dieser Spiel...
Ja.
Dieser Spielmodus, der geht immer so ewig lange.
Und jetzt gibt's draw.
Pass auf.
Wie viel haben wir noch?
Zwo Minuten?
Eine Minute?
Eine.
Oh, nee.
Einfach nur eine.
Okay.
Das heißt, entweder klappt die ersten eineinhalb Attacks oder es ist jebaited.
Ja, es hängt davon ab, ob die Leute jetzt anfangen zu tilten und Scheiße bitten.
Scheiße.
Oh, Wahnsinn, ey.
Man hat bei Mercy gar keine Hitstats.
Wird gar nicht angezeigt.
Weapon Accuracy.
Wer braucht das?
Mercy meint's nicht.
Chosen, das hab ich auch schon gehört, dass man jetzt Merky sagt.
Manche Leute sprechen das so ähnlich an wie Murky.
Murky.
So wie der Held aus Hotz.
Und die ganz coolen Leute sagen jetzt auch Luxio.
Luxio.
Weil er so Luxus ist?
Keine Ahnung.
Weil die alle Dachschaden haben.
Ja.
Da ein Stück Joey Alcohol von mir.
Der hier fühlt sich der Update von Game Guy aus im Sang.
Ich mach das jetzt für dich.
Vor einil.
Mal sehen wie das aussieht, guck mal.
paralleleon.
Ja.
Die Damage-Boost-Taktik, die geht immer wieder.
Das ist der Wahnsinn.
Jetzt gucken wir uns das mal an.
Und er kommt noch nicht mal hin.
Das war calculated.
33 Prozent, wir hatten drei Spieler im Team.
Warum habe ich wohl 33 Prozent?
Jetzt können wir ein bisschen Pause machen.
Wir sind jetzt bei 4-1.
Ich habe erst nach den ersten zwei Matches angefangen, den Counter.
Und die ersten zwei Matches waren ja 1-1.
Ich habe dich fast eingeholt.
Kurze Aufgabe, sechs, sieben Minuten.
Bis gleich.
Oh, was trinken.
Und Leute, was sagt ihr zu meinem High-Octane-Mercy-Gameplay?
Mixerchips highen hier.
In der Mache.
Ganz schön krasse Mucke.
Übelst geile Mucke.
Sowas höre ich eigentlich normalerweise.
Geht es darum, wie irgendein Feuerriese die Welt verbrennt?
So wie das für ordentliche Metal-Texte sich gehört?
Warte mal, bis der Eax wieder da ist.
Ein bisschen Headbang-Musik laufen.
Was, du findest das Geschrei mega nervig?
Das ist das Beste.
Wir können noch mehr schreien lassen.
Kannst du crawlen? Nein.
So, ich glaube, im Text geht gerade die Welt unter oder sowas.
Aber wenn schon, dann richtig.
Hört sich an wie Roadhog.
Destroyer.
Gleich mal ins Impure-Drop.
Aber ich kann verstehen, dass das nicht nach jedermanns Geschmack ist.
Wir können ein bisschen was Klassischeres anmachen.
Also, was Klassischeres Metal-technisch.
Was ist das da zum Beispiel?
Nein, ich spiele kein Beethoven.
Ich spiele kein Beethoven-Spiel.
Aber wenn ich Klassik spielen würde, dann da auch ein bisschen was epischeres.
Ortin fragt, ist Rating 3318 gut?
Ja, das ist ganz gut. Statistisch gesehen ist es nicht schlecht.
Bist du so in den Top 20%?
Top 20? 15 bis 20?
Metallica hat schon ganz nette Sachen gemacht.
Auch wenn der Drummer gehatet wird zur Zeit von allen Seiten.
Auch in den letzten Jahren schon.
So, ich guck jetzt mal wie viele Aufrufe mein letztes Witt schon hat.
Battlefield. Hat einfach schon mal 10k Aufrufe, ne?
Also für ein Video, was ich quasi vormittags an einem Wochentag hochgeladen habe, ist das schon relativ viel.
Ich war glaube ich einer der ersten, was zum Thema Bad Company 3 hochgeladen hat heute.
Das wäre so geil, wenn es Bad Company 3 gibt.
Geil, wenn es Bad Company 3 wäre.
Ich spamm jetzt mal in die...
Ich bin noch in so einer Skype-Gruppe.
So einer Battlefield-Skype-Gruppe. Da spamm ich jetzt rein.
Stimmt das?
Wat?
Ich kann mich bei Skype nicht mehr einloggen.
Was ist das?
Just a moment. Create new account.
Nein!
Ich will meinen alten Account verwenden.
Fuck.
Kokosnuss-Boy.
Äh, subben. Gibt es noch nicht.
Habe ich auch bis jetzt noch mich null darum gekümmert, dass ich einen Sub-Button kriege oder einfach...
Also, sag mal so, dass ich Affiliate werden soll, spammt dich ja Twitch quasi sobald du ein paar Viewer hast zu.
Aber um Partner und sowas habe ich mir überhaupt keine Gedanken gemacht.
Wenn du donaten möchtest, kannst du auf der Profilseite gucken. Da gibt es unten einen Donation-Link.
Aber wie gesagt, es muss hier keiner donaten.
Wenn es euch gefällt, reicht mir das.
Cooperation mit Katja, krasser Witze.
Doggy-Style 3.0.
Doggy-Style NG.
Was für Comments unter dem Video gibt es jetzt?
Are you alive? 100 pro.
War klar, war klar.
Ich glaube, das ist das Einzige, was er bei Live-Konzerten sagt.
Josen, du musst ja gar keinen Kappa dahinter machen.
Im Jahr 2017 und fast 2018 ist es überhaupt keine Sache, sowas öffentlich zuzugeben.
Ah, 263 Comments.
Die Comment-Anzahl schwenkt, ob ich nach Top-Kommentaren sortiere oder nach neuesten Kommentaren.
YouTube-Logik.
Ich sehe da, Patrick hat die Lyrics studiert von Katjas Song.
So, wieder da.
Kann ich queuen?
Danke.
Dann...
Queue ich.
Äh, Ritchie können wir später machen.
Wir duo-queuen jetzt erstmal noch ein bisschen.
Oder ich weiß nicht, ob später, ich bin...
Machen wir mal Uptime, ich muss mal Uptime gucken.
Uptime.
Wann bin ich denn schon on?
Schon 2 Stunden 20.
Ne, wahrscheinlich heute, heute kein Overwatch mehr oder vielleicht später noch.
So.
Der Chat, ne, die haben jetzt die letzte Runde einfach komplett geflamed.
Von quasi 2. Runde bis, bis 3. Runde.
Durchgängig.
Wir haben ein Game.
Hollywood.
Vielleicht darf ich, vielleicht darf ich wieder was, was spielen.
Was nicht Mercy ist.
Ich warte mal.
Warum picken die alle Moira?
Hat halt nen großen, äh, Laser.
Meinst du?
Die verbinden damit was?
Ja.
Oder kompensieren damit was?
Ja, den längsten hat sie ja, ne?
Den längsten Laser.
Den längsten hat sie, ja.
Ich glaub die längste Nase von allen Overwatch Charakteren auch.
Hm.
Ich muss sagen, Moira ist das erste Design von allen Overwatch Helden, was mich nicht anspricht.
Also was mir, was mir vom Design her nicht gefällt.
Aber wahrscheinlich weil sie irgendwie so, so, so, so knochig und dünn und...
Keine Ahnung.
Gefällt mir nichts.
Also mir gefällt überhaupt kein neuer Held.
Außer Anna.
Sombra find ich nice.
Sombra find ich nice gemacht.
Anna auch.
Orisa, okay.
Aber die hat auch Liebe zum Detail.
Wenn man sich anguckt, ähm, also quasi wie sie das mit den Augen gemacht haben.
Also das ist, ich finde, ich finde die alle ganz gut.
Liebe zum Detail, ey.
Was ist das hier?
Ist das ein Dice Game?
Also Overwatch 1 kann man Overwatch nicht absprechen, das Liebe zum Detail hat.
Ich mach jetzt, pass auf, ich mach jetzt den Pro Fire Strike.
Wart mal, wie viele Sekunden macht man den?
Ja.
Perfekte Plays
Zu Tode gespendet
Da sieht man meine jahrelange Main-Tank-Erfahrung wieder richtig gut
Hi, lohnt sich noch Overwatch? Klar
Lohnt sich noch
Ich geh an Kart ran
Der Roadhog will mich ficken
Der Roadhog fickt mich, weil mich keiner heilt
Ich hab gleich Shatter
Ihr macht das schon
Zocken das noch viele? Ja klar
Also Multiplayer-Shooter- beziehungsweise Hero-Shooter-technisch gibt es kein Spiel, was so viel gespielt wird wie Overwatch
Auch wenn die Spieler-Zahlen schon deutlich weniger geworden sind
Hanzo ist in Main
Die gehen hoch, die wollen glaube ich High-Crown, entweder flanken sie links oder gehen High-Crown
Äh, ich bin oben
Ich bin noch an Kart dran
Fuck
Wo sind alle hin?
Warum sind alle hinterm Haus?
Alterlala, gibt's doch nicht
Ich dachte, es sind noch ein paar Leute hinter mir
Wusste gar nicht, dass ich da alleine bin
Zwar Huge Shatter, Big Slam war das
Ich conteste den Kampf immer
Alle slow, aber nix trauen
Geht nix trauen, ne
Haha, der Frasier ist am Start
Was mach ich denn mal?
Reinhard ging gar nicht
Haben sofort gehabt
Ich bin hier, ich bin hier
Ich bin hier, ich bin hier, ich bin hier
Ersp intimidiert
Ich frag mich um Kapital
Er ist vermisst
Er kommt vor
Aber er kommt
Nur genommen
So wahrscheinlich
Wo tut scumbag Chineseélé
Die steuern sind all das
Ich bin hier
Du bist jetzt da
Ich william, wo bist du?
Ja, der geht links oben, der Winston.
Fuck, Mann, da geht ja gar nichts.
Du kriegst keinen Fuß auf den Boden gerade.
Ja, wir spielen halt mit dem Token.
Das geht noch nicht.
Die Mercy geht ran.
Ich bleib dran.
Geh ran.
Hey, wir haben Fight gewonnen.
Fuck yeah.
Payload.
Ich bleib mal am Payload stehen.
Wird das Spiel noch lange am Leben bleiben?
Das hängt von Blizzard ab.
Ich hab Defense Matrix auf,
ich muss weg.
Geht nicht, war weg.
Ich hab ihn, ich hab ihn, abgefangen.
Ich hab gleich Ulti, ich hab gleich Ulti.
Nicht mal lang.
Oh, ich schlafe, ich schlafe.
Pass auf, da kommt ein McPhee runter.
Du wirst übrigens nicht geheilt,
die haben da keinen Bock drauf.
Gibt's nicht.
Nein.
Oh, zum Glück ins Bett.
Ich hab Ulti.
Ich hau's gleich.
Fuck, da stand da gar keiner.
But why?
Der Reaper ist irgendwo hingeportet.
Aufgeräumt.
Alter, alles geregelt.
Alter, ja, ja.
Ich hab's gesehen, alles weggehauen.
Nein, meins.
Der Lusio, ey.
Reaper, Reaper am Card, Reaper am Card.
Ach, die haben ja kaum noch Zeit.
Ich dachte, die haben noch übelst viel Zeit.
Oh, nee.
Shit.
Passt aber.
Bing.
Okay, jetzt durchpushen und wir haben's.
Also, wenn ich jetzt keinen Playoff der Game kriege,
bin ich stark beleidigt.
Erinnere mich dran, dass ich uns nicht rausziehe.
Sagen Nope.
Oh.
Hättest du Play on?
Kokosnuss-Boy.
Yes.
Du gehst einfach auf das Profil
oder scrollst runter auf meinem Kanal
und da steht links Donations.
Es sei denn, du trollst mich.
Du musst einfach auf das Profil gehen.
Auf das Profil und dann steht dann so Dinger wie
Wie funktioniert das hier?
Lull, mein ist mein Avatar.
Da unten steht Donations, YouTube, Twitter.
Du musst einfach auf das Profil gehen.
Willst du Reinhardt?
Ich muss wohl.
Reinhardt als Reinhardt?
Ich muss wohl Reinhardt spielen.
Aber so hat es, es hat auch irgendwo alles seinen Vorteil, ne?
So lerne ich auch mal andere Helden spielen.
Mhm.
Sogar Mercy.
Weißt du, was ich meine?
Weißt du noch früher?
Ich hab mich ja wirklich immer drum gedrückt, Mercy zu spielen.
War ja gar nicht möglich eigentlich, mich zu Mercy spielen zu bewegen.
Aber das ist auch stark verständlich.
Also der Held ist halt echt nicht geil.
Wenn du wenigstens selber ziehen müsstest mit deinem Stab, ne?
Ja.
Das verstehe ich bei Moira auch nicht.
Warum sie bei Moira so eine Halb-Auto-Mechanik wieder reingemacht haben.
Ich meine, du musst nicht so, es ist nicht Winston oder Symmetra quasi, ne?
Wo du einfach nur in die Richtung guckst.
Aber es ist auch nicht komplett Hitscan drauf.
Verstehe ich nicht.
Metz doch ein bisschen.
Achtung, ich geh mal ein bisschen zur Seite.
Frage, ob wir da durchkommen.
Nein!
Wie kann man denn da picken?
Mein Schild ist weg.
Aber jetzt wird zurückgespamt.
Zack, zack.
Mach das, ja.
Schild ist aufgeladen.
Fuck, fuck, hier sind alle Symmetra.
Symmetra-Torrets.
Oh, die D.Va pusht mich.
Ja, ich hab kein Schild mehr.
Da kommt was.
Nein.
Ich hab versucht, ein bisschen Old-Charge zu farmen.
DP hab ich dann.
Weiß, ich bin tot.
Ich muss erst wieder vor-Garage kommen.
Wieso spielt der Zigeuner eigentlich Widow, wenn die so viele Schilder haben?
Oh, ich bin getrappt.
Was ist das?
Spam!
Fuck, Alter!
Ich hab Shatter.
Ich brauch Heal, ich brauch Heal.
Ich krieg keinen Heal.
Und wer ist jetzt Arnie auf mir?
Mann, warum schießt da keiner auf die fucking Säure dran?
Okay, ich shatter jetzt rein, dann nachswitch ich.
Das ist übelst für den Arsch unten auf einer Front mit Schild gerade.
Sind wir jetzt alle da?
Nee, noch nicht ganz.
Okay, die sind drauf.
Also, mehr kann ich jetzt nicht machen.
Mercy ist down.
Oh.
Weißt du was?
Ich geh jetzt Winston und spring aufs Dach.
Bleib lieber rein, Hort. Die haben eh noch den Hanzo.
Weißt du?
Ja, ja.
Ah, die Mercy, die verlässt mich die ganze Zeit.
Nachdem das Tire drei Stunden im Kreis gefahren ist.
Och, Mercy!
Ah, gut.
Das bringt nix gerade, da vorzugehen.
Das sind immer Unterzahl.
Rechts Soldier.
Ich werd gleich das kotzen, ey.
Pharah ist so effektiv.
Was ist denn hier? Wo sind denn alle?
Da ist ja durchs Sack alles rein, aber das ist auch null Support da.
Pass auf, die Zarya geht jetzt rein. Stirb.
Müsstest du einfach nur auf mir dranbleiben, dann kann ich auch was machen.
Achtung, Achtung, jetzt machen wir einfach mal das Tire kaputt.
Jawoll.
Okay, auf geht's.
Ey.
Die Moira, ey.
Der Wahnsinn.
Ich geb auf.
Macht keinen Sinn.
Ich bin dran.
WTF?
Was ist das?
Schämen wir jetzt auch mal an. Ich switch jetzt.
Triple kill, mehr geht jetzt nicht.
Es ging auch wirklich grad nix vorwärts.
Ich wusste auch nicht, was ich mit dem Reinhardt machen sollte.
Lasst noch mal coopen, ihr Leute. Lasst noch mal ordentlich coopen und dann gehen wir rein.
Die Moira ist halt voll für den Arsch. Die läuft die ganze Zeit rein und feedet.
Ich bin bei dir.
Hey, wir haben was gekillt.
Huge.
Big.
Ganz auf der Payload.
Nein, nein, bleib du drauf.
Ich brauch die Position.
Ich hätte eigentlich auch aufs Dach gewollt, so.
McQueen low.
Nice.
Pfuh.
Ich war zu fett.
Der ist fast down.
Ich hab den McQueen.
Auto wieder am Start.
Oder?
Ne.
Da ging jetzt nicht so viel.
Soll ich drin bleiben?
Play of the Game oder so?
Ah ja, Play of the Game. Genau.
Da bin ich schon mal gespannt.
Was ist das?
Bling. Ups.
Das ist nicht alles.
Ne, das war, als die durchgepusht sind. Ne, das ist das gar nicht.
Das ist, als die durchgepusht sind, bis du die von der Seite abgefarmt hast.
Hm. Wird auch eh die Hälfte.
Ist doof.
Ärgerlich.
Egal.
Suckt.
Aber die Moira fand ich gar nicht mehr zum Kotzen.
Das war schrecklich.
Ich wusste überhaupt nicht, was ich machen sollte als Reinhard zwischendurch.
Die Leute sind links und rechts gestorben.
Das hat überhaupt keine Auswirkung gehabt auf das Game.
Also für mich gab das nur 19 Abzug.
Ich hab auch nicht viel verloren.
20?
Ne.
Oder 15.
15.
15 Abzug nur.
Fabian bist noch da?
Jawoll.
Gescheite Map.
Sonst mal bitte was anderes als Main Tank und Mercy.
Du musst aber also ziemlich schnell Lucio anlocken.
Ich lock mal Ana ein.
Ana ist eines der Supports, die mir echt den meisten Bock macht.
Eigentlich müsste ich jetzt, wenn wir eine gute Com haben wollen, mit Rats und so,
muss ich jetzt Mercy nehmen.
Aber wir gucken mal.
Wir gucken mal.
Hm.
Moira.
Oh mein Gott.
Komm, ich mach Huge Mercy Plays.
Wollen wir gewinnen.
Mercy ist einfach so OP.
Leute, jetzt wird es wieder spannend.
Es ist da durch.
Wo ich vorhin auf K war, hast du in deinem Chat eigentlich deine Huge Mercy Plays gezeigt?
Ja.
J catalysts.
Ich habe PERFORMANCE Mercy Plays gezeigt.
So deine Highlights.
Ach so, habe ich gar nicht dran gedacht.
Stimmt, das geht ja.
Nah.
Kann ich gleich machen, meine Huge Mercy Plays.
Warte, ihr macht auch so ein ekliges Geräusch beim Fliegen, piepst so.
Jetzt hast du es gemerkt, ne?
Ja.
Иnter Genji will sterben.
Diese Scheißkugel, man.
Hi, hallo?
Ich muss den Reinhard heilen.
Das ist unser Roadhog. Rechts ist irgendwas. Genji ist rechts.
Ich versuche den mal durchzuhallen. Geht nicht. Achtung, huge, huge Ress.
Hahaha. Huge Ress. Ey, kannst du mal probieren, scheiß drauf. Oh man. Ich habe keinen Bock, diesen gar keinen zu spielen.
Aber das lustige ist, du wirst nie geplamed als Mercy irgendwie.
Oh, warte mal, wenn du Mercy one trick pony die Mercy wegnimmst, dann wirst du geplamed.
Ja, das dürfen die auch gerne spielen. Ist schon okay. Ich habe ja gar keine Ambitionen drauf.
Halt mich, ich mache Ulti. Lass mich mal zu dir hochfliegen. Okay, passt.
Oh Leute, nicht verrecken. Ich habe dich. Oh, ich hätte einen retzen können.
Ich hätte einen retzen können, habe ich nicht. Huge. Huge Place.
Links kommt was. Du hast Damage Boost. Oh, ich habe Damage gekriegt. Muss mich kurz verstecken.
Puh. Ist der Battlefield-Surfer ab hier oder müsste er ab sein?
Leute, Reinhard, Punish, Punish, Punish. Wo ist das Punishment? Gibt es nicht.
Oh nein. BTF. Kannst du mich fressen? Äh, ich weiß gar nicht wo. Ach da. Hä? Hä?
Kannst du mich retzen? Lol.
Warte, ich helfe dir. Rück E.
Gab das? Äh, ja, ich lebe wieder.
Leute, das ist der perfekte Weg hier, den ich gelaufen bin. Vom Spawn zu unseren Leuten.
Außen rum. Man darf es den Gegnern auch nicht zu schwer machen.
Hinter euch, McCree.
Halt den Sniper an.
Lol. War der McCree auf dem Sensor im Kopf drauf?
Ich habe wieder auf.
Ich habe wieder ult.
Bing.
Dudelfahrt.
Ich höre oben irgendwas.
Äh, ah, noch.
Links. Damage boost.
Puh, puh.
Pioch-maß. Es ist eigentlich lächerlich, wie viel Impact man hat mit einfach nur links klicken und grob in Richtung Teammates gucken.
Was?
Nein, ey.
Ich hole dich.
Diese One-Hit-Combo.
Egal, jetzt sind wir raus.
Rekt.
Passt schon.
Haha, Bob-Champ-Chat, genau.
Haha, in so einem unglaublichen Place.
Mach gleich Ulti, halt die Heilung auf mir.
Ja, mache ich.
What?
Hä?
Rewart runter.
Links, links.
Oh, Reinhardt.
Oh, nice.
Null.
Nice so.
Ich muss unseren Roadhog heilen.
Jetzt dich.
Damage boost.
Leute, ich bin runtergefallen.
Lasst mich hochfliegen.
Ich, ich, ich retze unseren Reinhardt.
McCree, unten in der Tankstelle.
Pass auf.
Nein.
Fuck.
Ich bin runtergefallen.
Lass mich hochfliegen.
Ich, ich, ich retze unseren Reinhardt.
McCree, unten in der Tankstelle.
Pass auf.
Ich, ich, ich retze unseren Reinhardt.
Fuck.
Das war genau in dem Moment, wo ich runtergefallen bin.
Uuuh.
Nuke Mercy.
Learn to play.
Ah, du machst das, du regelst das, sehe ich.
Wo ist denn der Sai nun?
Gleich wieder da.
Genji über euch, über dir.
Okay.
Nice.
Ich bin hochgeflasht.
Der Frasier.
Fabian und Abend level ich, wenn ich hier fertig bin und werde weitergelevelt.
Okay.
Wo hat mein Handy vibriert?
Was ist da los?
Ja, aber wir müssen es haben, wenn man ein anständiges
Team-Setup, ne?
Haben wir?
Oh!
Mind blown.
Komplett.
Du musst zwar Mercy spielen und dich aufopfern, aber...
Ja, da muss man durch.
Übrigens, Fabian,
du weißt ja, wir müssen zu Weihnachten
noch was aufnehmen zusammen.
Ich hab das jetzt ja schon seit einem Jahr über angedroht.
Kommst du mit?
Nur Noobs gehen durch die Mitte.
Bin Noob.
Wo ist mein Damage-Post?
Ja, ich musste auch mal...
Also auch wenn es schwer vorstellbar ist,
mal was anderes machen.
Ich komm mit jetzt.
Easy flank.
Ich hätte den Genji schon längst killen können.
Oh, die sind alle auf der rechten Seite.
Achtung, Achtung.
Oben rechts. Komm, wir gehen jetzt hin.
Easy flank.
Ich muss runter.
Ich bin runtergetroppt.
Was? Blumfel.
Gefistet.
Drecksjar.
Du bist einfach so hässlich gestunt
und bist tot.
Die sind einfach so gestorben.
Au.
Ich bin doch nicht wieder da, ne?
Es wäre nice, wenn du mich zu euch fliegen lässt.
Juhu.
Aber jetzt komm mal mit.
High-Octane-Gameplay, ihr seht's schon.
Der Typ ist...
Ich werde gleich gefistet, Achtung.
Ey, eine Moira saugt an mir.
Ich bin down.
Will ich das anhören, oder?
Ihr macht das schon.
Du willst gerade so lachen,
dass ich daneben geschossen habe.
Das war aber doch...
Das hat doch genau gestimmt, oder?
Easy win.
Guck mal, ich hab sogar nur...
Ich hab sogar nur Silber-Heal mittlerweile.
So.
Hast du irgendwie...
Potge, wo du gucken musst?
Weiß ich nicht, vielleicht.
Nö.
Flank-Taktik, ey.
Der Wahnsinn.
Beste, oder?
Beste.
MVP.
Neue Season, ey.
Noch 200, dann sind wir im Master.
Ja.
Und ich hab dich fast eingeholt.
Noch 8 Punkte.
Gut.
Gut so.
Nachdem ich ja auch immer meine besten Helden rausholen muss hier.
Reinhard und Mercy.
Weißt du?
Hallo?
Ich glaube, das sind die zwei Helden,
die ich seit Release am...
Naja, ne, ist okay.
Sowas wie Genji hab ich auch nicht gespielt.
Aber im Prinzip, ja.
Das sind die Helden, die ich mit am wenigsten gespielt hab.
Oh, wir haben ein Game.
Oh, ich mach mal wieder Speed.
Ich muss mal was anderes spielen.
Nimm eurer Saugt an mir.
Eurer Saugt.
Pass auf, wir kriegen jetzt ne Moira als zweiten Heiler.
Warum sind die Leute alle so geil auf Moira?
Kommt heute noch BF?
Ähm, ja, guckt bei mir auf dem YouTube-Channel.
Da gab's heute BF.
Sogar mit, mit Huge League.
Mittlerweile schon 12k Views hat.
Geht ab.
Übrigens, wenn ich da so sinnlos in der Gegend rumschieße,
liegt das nicht daran, weil ich wirklich sinnlos in der Gegend rumschieße,
sondern weil ich auf einem anderen Monitor,
ähm, in meinem YouTube-Channel rumklicke
und ich den Overwatch, äh, Raw-Input anhab.
Oder anscheinend Raw-Input an ist.
Das heißt, die Maus ist jetzt doppelt.
Die Maus ist jetzt in meinem linken Bildschirm und der Hund in Overwatch.
Perfekt.
What the fuck?
Ja.
Das ist ja mega-Multitasking.
Ja, ich bin, ich guck mir gerade hier...
Kommst du nirgends oben raus?
...comments an.
Ja.
Oder nimm die Leute aus der Mitte mit.
Jetzt bin ich verwirrt.
Ich bin jetzt ganz hinten.
Aber zum Glück kann man Warn-Speed boosten.
Sind die Gegner?
Tracer? Tracer?
Nee, oder?
Haben wir keinen Tank?
Zarya.
Die ist fast down, die Moira.
Oh nein!
Voll in den Roadhog reingerannt, der wiedergekommen ist.
Puh.
Wollte nur vom Genji abhauen.
Sei wieder da.
Wieder da.
Sei Ulti.
Ah, komm.
Lieber Hund bei uns.
Ah, ich hab Ulti.
Ich hab Ulti.
Nevermind.
Da ist ein Roadhog.
Nice Shield.
Oh puh, ich dachte die hatten noch ein Shield.
Ich find den ja nicht so nice.
Bisschen doofes Timing gewesen.
Äh, Spot.
Ich dachte die pushen jetzt.
Hook ist weg.
Braucht er nicht hier.
Bin ich am Arsch.
Äh, was hat...
Diese Hitbox von dem Schwert, na?
Das ist teilweise 5 Kilometer gefühlt.
Riegerup.
Ich glaub wir müssen unseren Leuten da vorne helfen.
Wo ist er hin?
Fast down.
Woah.
Die Tracer ist auf mir.
Fuck, ich bin down.
Aber das müssten wir haben.
Ein bisschen wenig Leben rein.
Bin mit Speed gleich wieder da.
Nächsten Fight krieg ich wahrscheinlich meine Ulti, wenn ich ein bisschen lebe.
Fuck.
Für nen kurzen Moment hab ich gedacht wir haben C9.
Und hab's noch nicht eingenommen.
Das wäre der Wahnsinn gewesen so.
Hättest du es nicht für möglich gehalten?
Hätt schon sein können.
Hätt passieren können.
So nach dem Motto.
Speed ist an, nur zwei Gegner da.
Auf sie, druff, bashen.
Oh, Punkt nicht.
Cap.
Also ihr könnt, macht Ausrufezeichen Server, dann kriegt ihr nen Battlelog-Link zu dem Battlefield-Server.
Willst du Mercy machen, schnell?
Ja.
Bleib nur auf mir.
Wir klären das.
Easy, easy man.
Ich hab das Movement-System von Mercy immer noch nicht verstanden.
Wie man Boost kriegt und wie nicht.
Okay, so kriegt man anscheinend Boost.
Bum, bum.
Ich bin auf dir drauf.
Unsere Moira kann da drüben auch was heilen.
Oh, ich seh dich net.
Wo bist du?
Oben.
I Octane Mercy Gameplay.
Komm mal ein Stückchen zurück.
Ich geh auf die andere Seite, komm mit.
Ja, komm mit.
Easy.
Moment, fuck.
Ich checke diesen Rats nicht.
Wie funktioniert der überhaupt?
Ich dachte, du hast irgendwie zwei Rats oder so, wenn du das Ding anmachst.
Chat, erklärt mir mal Mercy.
Ich dachte, man kriegt zwei Rats, wenn man die Ulti anmacht.
Hä?
Bist du noch am Leben am Spot?
Nee, ich bin an dir dran.
Ich bin auf unserem Genji.
Ich bin weg.
Aber wir haben 80%.
Ach, wenn dein normaler Rats auf cool...
Der Joseon kennt sich aus.
Also am besten ist, ich heb mir meinen Rats auf, mach Valkyrie an und kann zweimal ratzen.
Verstehe.
Die gehen übrigens rechts gerade.
Ja, aber ich will flanken.
Die haben jetzt auch noch Pharah.
Der wird gerätzt.
Darf man, Joseon, wenn du dich damit auskennst, darf man beim Rätzen weggucken?
Darf man, Joseon, wenn du dich damit auskennst, darf man beim Rätsen weggucken?
Ich komm zu dir rüber.
Hinter uns ist irgendwas gelaufen.
Damage Boost.
Gut.
Kommt da vielleicht was?
Ich glaub's nicht.
Wenn, dann nur Scheiße.
Okay, man kann auch beim Rätzen von den Leuten weggucken, die man rätst.
Okay, man kann auch beim Rätsen von den Leuten weggucken, die man rätst.
Das ist gut zu wissen.
Jetzt! One-Click! Ding, ding, ding!
Bestimmt Kack.
Ja, das ist die Kacke.
Guck dir das an. Zack, zack.
Was ist da im Play of the Game?
Da siehst du mal, wenn das schon Play of the Game ist...
Ja, wieso? Du hast vier Leute gekillt.
Ich fand's mega bad.
Ich geh raus, ne?
Aber heut läuft's.
Dank meiner Huge Mercy Plays, natürlich.
Ey, das gab jetzt fast überhaupt keine Punkte.
Jetzt bist du noch drei entfernt.
Ich hab relativ viel gekriegt, glaub ich.
Was hatte ich denn vorher?
18 oder so?
Nee, 13. 13 hatte ich, glaub ich, vorher.
20.
Was hältst du eigentlich von den SR-Änderungen in Season 8?
Ich find das gut.
Für wir als Flexspieler ist das halt auch gut.
Ja, grade da.
Man müsste halt noch ein bisschen mehr machen.
Wie gesagt, ich hab's jetzt schon oft gesagt in den letzten paar Streams.
Ich find's absurd, dass wir keine Team-Queue haben.
Ah, nee, nee, nee, nee.
Warum?
Na gut.
Schon wieder dasselbe Team.
Zum dritten Mal jetzt.
Okay, nein!
Wir haben jetzt zum dritten Mal das gleiche Team.
Gold und Silber.
Moment, was ist das für ein Gegnerteam?
Silber!
Oh man.
Was? Na gut, die haben viel Geld.
Die haben...
Die haben 4er-Strike mit 2 unranked.
Mal gucken, was die letzte Runde waren.
Hoodie, Yehut, Hoodcache und...
...Squiddly.
Ich könnte wieder probieren.
Naja, die waren das letzte Mal so gerankt.
Ja doch, machen.
Everyone focus the Silver Player.
Der eine war sogar Master.
Im Gegnerteam letzte Runde.
Letzte Season.
Ist klar.
Oh, der Junk hat gepresst ihn.
Rohtok, neben uns.
Ich bin fast down.
Kannst dann nachher neu starten.
Wenn wir uns unseren Reinhardt mal heilen.
Der YOLOt.
Ich seh nix.
Mach, dass ich Gegner finde.
Jetzt gehen wir mal schön an den Arsch der Welt.
Moment, hinter uns ist ein Zen.